this is Jocko podcast number 225 with
echo Charles and me Jocko will Inc good
evening echo good evening last month I
went to a memorial service and it was
the first memorial service that I had
been to for a long time that wasn't
forest seal it was the first memorial
service I had been to for a long time
that was for someone who died of natural
causes a memorial service for someone
that had actually lived their full life
expectancy 80 80 years or maybe 82 years
or 83 I don't I don't remember the exact
number which is kind of interesting in
its own right because when someone
that's younger dies then everyone talks
about their age you know everyone says
he was only 26 so he was just 28 he was
only 32 then I've been too far too many
funerals and memorial services like that
far too many funerals where the morning
that is taking place is about what is
never going to get done potential that
wasn't reached
a life that was cut short but this this
memorial was for the patriarch of a
group of families who are friends with
my family then this man this old man had
three sons who are friends of mine and
those sons all have kids and all our
kids grew up together and we have done a
lot over the years surfing and camping
and climbing and playing music playing
music around the campfire or in the in
the little studio and I'm actually known
these guys for for over 20 years and
because I knew them I knew their old man
too and the old man was you know he was
a stud in his own right he was going
strong he was an athlete he was an
entrepreneur he liked sports and beer
and rock and roll and late nights then
again this guy was an older guy you know
75 78 80 years old in his later years
and and he poured everything he could
into his family into his kids and into
their kids and he was a good man and he
lived a good life and the memorial
service was you know a small kind of
private affair you know there was
probably I don't know 70 or 80 people
there you know all the extended family
with all the kids and friends the family
and some of his friends and it was
it was a nice service and I I said a few
words and I can I kind of you know told
a funny story I you know his his son had
spoke his sons had spoke and his wife
had spoke and it was his emotional and I
you know I I took the opportunity to
lighten the mood a little and what I
talked about is I talked about how he he
would listen when his sons and me would
play music back in the day he and we
would play for hours and he would listen
for hours and and listen when I talk
about us playing music I'm talking about
us just just jamming and riffing and
we're talking about songs that are 15 or
20 or 30 minutes long just just songs
that are just meandering through riffs
and bridges and verses and going from
just droning heavy thunder to like quiet
acoustic jams and all these different
songs to be played just one time in one
time only just impro improve and they're
hard to follow and they're hard to
understand and you know he and he would
stay down there and he would just listen
and he would rock out with us this this
old man then he like you could see it in
his face he loved it he loved listening
to us and you know look his sons are all
awesome musicians and I'm the I'm the
kind of not so awesome musician but even
the best musicians you know when you're
just kind
making stuff up as you go along it's not
gonna be it's not something that's super
easy to listen to and he would listen to
us with no expectations no criticism he
would enjoy it for what it was which
which was imperfect which was off time
which was maybe a little out of tune and
he would listen to with a big smile on
his face and later it got me thinking
about how often how often do we look at
things that are going on around us and
how often do we think if only that was a
little bit different if only that was a
little bit more in tune if only that
timing was a little bit tighter if only
if only this had happened a little bit
sooner that had happened a little bit
later we're constantly picking apart
what we see and that's a little lesson
the lesson I learned from the old man
because in the end even after eight
years or 90 years or a hundred years one
thing we're gonna still want is a little
more time
even forever is too short so don't waste
too much time wishing and hoping and
wanting for things to be different
instead sometimes you just gotta sit
back and you got a smile then you got to
enjoy the jam then listen to the music
for what it is imperfect out of tune off
time but real and with that it has been
a while since we've got a QA echo
Charles mm-hmm so let's rock and roll
let's jam yes sir what do we got
QA various questions from the interweb
all right first question chuckle I
failed to understand a task that was
given to me I take ownership that I
didn't ask the right questions but
extreme ownership applies to my boss too
as she didn't make sure that I
understood it correctly or is that a
poor excuse Oh so optimally in the world
of extreme ownership everybody takes
ownership and there are and I talked
about this with when Dave Burke was on
yes is that the its interlocking fields
of fires so the various people that are
trying to find solutions they overlap
and and problems get solved from two
different directions so the problems
get flanked when this is happening but
we can't guarantee always that everybody
takes ownership and we can't guarantee
that but that doesn't mean that we point
our fingers at someone say you need to
take ownership because oz as we know
when you do that people get defensive
and then they start blaming you so we
avoid that what we do is we take
ownership so what happens here in this
situation here's the possible outcomes
right if if you go to your boss and you
say to her you know you didn't make sure
I understood right you go cast that
blame there's a there's a decent chance
that Jesus where you actually did you
actually need to pay attention that's
not on me and if you don't understand
you need to ask questions so nothing she
doesn't change anything
mm-hmm she hasn't changed anything and
you by the way you've created a little
bit of an antagonistic relationship here
because you're pointing the finger so
that doesn't really help
now here's another possible outcome you
know you go and you say hey look I
failed to make sure that I understood
this task
do you mind next time if I give you a
quick read back of what I think the task
is to make sure that I understand it but
so I'm taking full ownership like this
is on me I need to do this and now what
you're more likely to get in this
situation is you know the boss to say oh
you know of course absolutely you know
what next time let me make sure I give
you more detailed explanation so that
you have a better understand that's on
me and all of a sudden we've got this
problem getting solved from two
directions now there's also a chance
that when you say hey when you when you
say something you know hey let me let me
um little nation let me do a read back
with you you might say all that and she
goes yeah cool you you should do that
whatever pay more attention in which
case right so she's not taking any
ownership she's like yeah you should
have which is the big theorem people
always have in their head though when
when I say something's my fault people
go yeah it is and now they go wait a
second it's not supposed to work like
that yes
it is because when you take ownership of
the problem I go you know what I should
have asked you questions she goes yeah
you should have and you go yeah exactly
that's what I just said and now you ask
questions and now you make sure you
fully understand the task and now the
problem solved mmm so yeah I I think
when you ask that question you had the
suspicion What did he say is that a poor
excuse so you had the suspicion that was
that you were maybe perhaps
unfortunately making a little bit of an
excuse but you're correct it is a poor
excuse take ownership pay in an ideal
world
they'll P person above you in the chain
of command takes ownership as well but
you can't you can't force them to take
ownership yeah so solve the problem take
ownership and get it solved I mean kind
of when you think of it do you and this
actually may be a follow-up question hmm
maybe when you think about it when you
have the expectation reasonable or not
the expectation that other people have
to take ownership to isn't that
essentially negating your whole extreme
ownership yes whether it negates it or
not I don't know your hope is look the
hope is when I tell you I start taking
ownership other people start taking
ownership as well but I can't
necessarily control that alright I can't
force them to take ownership yeah you
know I can I can say hey that's your
part of the project you should have done
it they go okay well whatever I don't
think so right that there's a me forcing
ownership on you doesn't really work
what I should do is take ownership what
I hope is when I take ownership of your
part of the project you go hey jock oh
you know what that's actually something
that's actually my department let me let
me take that yeah that's something I
should be right I go okay cool great so
you just took ownership yes but if you
don't take ownership Roger that I got it
and I'm run right yeah and the
genuineness where this is this was a
question like that
penny you guys we get asked a lot like
well you know when you know it would a
lot of times be about the other person
taking ownership elsewhere you all right
which is crazy but yeah you you kind of
have that hope you actually do have that
hope yes you're sure
the actual like expectation that you
know we're like an expectation is there
that can't be let down yeah I can't be
mad at you right when you don't take
ownership look well I guess I can't be
mad at you but it doesn't help right
yeah you know if if you were supposed to
write a script for a for a freaking
advertisement that we were gonna do for
whatever sure I'm trying to think of
something cool if if we're gonna do an
advertisement and you were supposed to
write a script and then we show up and
you didn't do it and I'm like you know
what hey let me we'll come back tomorrow
I'll go home and write a script yeah and
you're like you what I would like you to
say is no hey you know what chocolates
actually I'm supposed to write the
script this whatever I'll do it
and I go okay cool but if you don't do
that you okay go go at the script um I
have to say okay got it
finally do some work now what do I learn
I learned that you're really not in the
game and now I'm probably gonna start
looking for someone else write scripts
yeah which isn't you which is but
actually give me some good ideas yeah
that genuineness though right with
yourself yes that's like if I was just
really if I'm just doing it cuz I'm if
I'm just doing it to get EKKO to do it
and I really don't want to take
ownership of it well no it's not what
we're talking about it's gonna jam you a
big gonna Jam me a big tough act it's
not as mad yeah it's kind of a step
backwards really like as far as problem
solving within the team kind of thing
but you're yeah you're gonna be mad and
resentful it's like man no one's like no
one's doing their work no one's taking
responsibility no one's right and you're
essentially in the same boat but just
one in one step behind you're kind of
like the problem is the opposite yeah
and I mean you can take this out to the
nth degree as well where I start taking
ownership of so many tasks and I can't
handle them all right detector you can
do that right and then then you go well
you know what we're not doing this over
here why aren't we getting that done cuz
I don't have the capacity because here's
what I'm doing I'm doing these other 19
things so that 20th thing it's not
happening now if you want to take
ownership of it and make it happen cool
you got my support but if not it's not
happening yeah and that's okay yeah it's
almost like when you kind of visualize
it mentally it's like there's like
levels and the extreme ownership is
always on the top
so certain developments can happen you
can take extreme ownership and then like
make certain moves and it'll jam it up
even more just because of the moves you
made not because you took extreme
ownership or took responsibility it's
because the some moves that you made in
proud solving problems which is all
natural but at the end of the day it is
on you like you have to take response
you have to truly say I'm gonna take
ownership yeah and believe it so that
again that genuineness to be like this
is my responsibility genuinely yes it's
yes it's easy to be like the the good
example is when someone says well you
know one of my subordinates made a
mistake you know of course of course I
get it just Ramona for good no I get it
but really it was their fault yeah you
know that's where it doesn't work yeah
and actually know what speak the next
question is similar we should jump into
the next question yes oh it's gonna lead
us down the same path of similar
conversations okay next question very
similar here it is my confusion is
everyone takes ownership at what level
does that end theoretically the
president is the commander in chief so
could take extreme ownership who decides
who gets fired how does that decision
get made is that an example of the
extreme ownership yeah so again this is
where we start looking at what this
looks like what when does it stop when
something goes wrong right when does it
stop so uh I was I was trying to apply
this to my life so with the blue on blue
right that I had so fratricide Ramadi
friendly-fire incident and I took
ownership of it now you got to remember
also about people below me in the chain
of command sidenote was my fault knows
my father said no it wasn't your fault
it was my fault the quote you know you
could say you could look at my boss and
go well why why wouldn't why wouldn't
your be your boss's fault why wouldn't
it be his boss's fault why wouldn't it
be their boss why wouldn't you take that
all the way up the chain of command to
the president of states who's the senior
person in the military chain of command
is the president and why wouldn't he say
hey Jacko's unit had a blue WOM
and it's my fault right theoretically
like that's what extreme ownership is
here's the deal
the goal of extreme ownership isn't just
to take ownership the goal of extreme
ownership is to actually solve the
problem that's what the goal is the goal
isn't to look who to blame the goal is
to get the problem solved that's what
the goal is it's not about just blaming
someone or finding someone to blame and
when you take ownership of it that is
the first step that leads us to solving
the problem but it's not the solution
itself so when you say oh it was my
fault the problem doesn't go away also
firing people firing someone is not
necessarily solve the problem now unless
that person a person in the chain of
command has proven to be incompetent or
immoral or incapable of doing their job
or blatantly negligent if it's one of
those than cool that might solve the
problem but most likely the people just
need to be led properly so so here's
what happened my boss listen to me give
a debrief and in the debrief yes I took
ownership but I didn't just take
ownership and say oh cool now it's gone
cuz it didn't make the problem disappear
I said hey here's the here's the new
standard operating procedures that we
are going to implement to make sure this
never happens again
okay so now he sees that I am solving
the problem he sees he sees that I
recognize what the problem is he sees
how I'm gonna get the problem solved the
problem is it is even getting past me
how can he take ownership it doesn't
make it past me I'm owning it now a good
boss is gonna say hey you know what
Jacque oh I get it and there's
definitely some I see what you're saying
however I could have done a better job
prepping you guys with training or
whatever right you know and I'm not
saying that was the case but you could
you can everyone can still kind of
provide
overlapping fields of fire to get a
problem solved now like I said I had
taken ownership of the problem and
offered the solutions if I had denied
any wrongdoing and blamed other people
and not come up with actual solutions
then he probably would have looked at me
man like uh you you're fired right
because you've got someone now that's
incompetent of seeing what the mistakes
were in confident figuring out the
solutions are
he needs to fire me yeah he needs to
fire me and the person above him the
chain of command will go hey what
happened with that fratricide Higa oh
yeah the the the commander out there
made the following mistakes and he's
obviously incompetent and I fired him
okay Roger that that's now we have a we
put a new person in there we start
moving in that direction but I solve the
problem that he saw that we all saw
right here's the solutions we're going
to use these marking procedures we want
to use these time distance think we're
gonna make sure that this does not
happen again
now if we go back to the base example
look it's one of the examples I use in
leadership strategy and tactics of a
machine gunner shoots out of his field
of fire okay machine gunner shoots out
of his field of fire maybe the machine
gunner says well you know once no one
told me what the fields of fire work
totals in my fault and then maybe the
fire team leader said I told him but he
didn't listen so you got two excuses
right and then the squad leader says
well you know the fire team the fire
team leader didn't effectively pass the
word so it's not my fault as a squad
leader the fire team leader has not
passed a word correctly and in a platoon
commander says well the squad leader
didn't understand the importance of
field to fire so it's actually is fault
so now we have everyone no one softly
you notice no one has solved the problem
in and then the task unit commander says
you know the platoon leader doesn't have
good control of his men so and still no
one solve the problem no one has
actually implemented a solution and in a
SEAL team commander the next person in
China command says the the task unit
didn't you know trained themselves
properly so so still he's just pointing
a finger it doesn't it doesn't solve the
problem and then the group commander
says the SEAL team commanding officers
out of touch with what his troops are
doing and then the group commander or
the Admiral says you know the group
commander's not paying attention to
training so still no one has solved the
problem all that's doing is blaming
we're just pointing fingers and then the
the the the the the SOCOM commander
looks at the Admiral and says the
Admirals
obviously driving realistic training you
know and so he's just blaming and then
the chairman of the Joint Chiefs of
Staff says you know obviously SOCOM has
no standards but they still won't do
anything and then the president says the
chairman of the Joint Chiefs of Staff
doesn't understand what's happening in
the field and then the voters say the
president doesn't know how to run the
military and then the president gets
voted out so the president eventually
gets fired because of this thing here
but that's not that's not what happens
so yeah yeah if you just pass the blame
pass the blame plaster blame and no one
takes ownership that I don't that that
problem continues throughout the whole
chain of command but when people start
taking ownership and then the problem
gets solved and it doesn't get anywhere
there's there becomes a limitation where
the problem is no longer a problem so if
the if the machine gunner shoots out of
his field of fire and says you know what
hey my fault next time I will confirm
that I know my field of fire before
pulling the trigger so that's that's
kind of a solved problem mm-hmm now it
gets overlapped a little bit because the
fireteam leader says listen I will make
sure and I'm probably perfectly clear
and reinforce and get a read back next
time I tell them what is field fires
I'll do a better job past Norton a got
like a double overlap on the problem
being solved and then the platoon leader
says listen I didn't I should have
covered fields of fire more in the
rehearsals so now we got triple so this
is not gonna be a problem anymore
no wonder fire you know no one to
reprimand the problem is getting solved
and you could go right up through the
chain of command you know that the
platoon leader says I'm gonna cover it
rehearsals and the task unit commander
says I'm gonna actually go through a
briefing on why fields of fire are so
important and you look at all these
stacks of people taking ownership the
problem doesn't get out the problem gets
solved so that's why a problem doesn't
make its way through the entire chain of
command when people start taking
ownership it gets owned and it gets
solved now if I got a bunch of people
that are blaming each other then maybe
someone has to get fired and one of the
platoons that I was putting through
training had a bad
assistant platoon commander and he
caused the platoon to fail multiple
training scenarios and the so every time
that little assistant platoon commander
will get put in charge of an element he
would make bad decisions and screw
things up and now whose fault is that
okay since the system platoon commander
he's causing the problem but his boss
mm-hmm I'm barely even talking to the
system sure I'm telling him hey
tactfully you did this wrong tackle you
did that wrong but I'm talking to
platoon commander go hey is this guy
capable hmm because he keeps making your
whole platoon fail now eventually the
platoon commander has to own that and
the platoon commander who has tried to
coach tried to mentor tried to you know
give the guy tactical instruction and
he's still not capable then guess what
the platoon commander takes ownership
and says you know what you're fired
so he took ownership of that problem
mm-hmm now does the task you too
commander need to fire the platoon
commander because not really because
there's no more problem the problems
gone and he goes okay you know I get it
you had to fire that guy so when you
take ownership of a problem you know
maybe it gets another layer up maybe two
layers up but it it doesn't just a
problem doesn't just continue forever
now you can have serious problems where
where it just continues I mean look at
Watergate right you know there was a
break-in people the trust was lost and
all of a sudden that problem with all
the way up through the chain of command
and the president resides so if it's bad
enough and no one takes ownership you
know if one of those got in and I free
I'd have to go into the details of
Watergate but you know sometimes you see
this where someone in the chain of
command goes this was all on me and then
usually people can wait a second are you
sure are you sure your boss didn't know
about this are you sure that his boss
didn't know about it and that's kind of
what from what I remember about
Watergate it was you know first you got
guys gonna it was just us we were acting
alone and then all of a sudden they
figure out no actually the president
knew exactly what was happening and
therefore he's you know gonna get gonna
get gonna get punished for it
so again I think the important thing
here is taking ownership is not about
figuring out who you should blame or who
you should fire now it's you know even
in extreme ownership I'm talking through
that problem in my own head or in the
blue on blue I'm saying like I'm trying
to figure out who to blame mm-hmm you
know and and I realize there's one
person to blame it's me once I do that
then it's not about like okay now I'm
gonna blame myself and now we're good no
it's how do I solve the problem so we
can win that's what ownership is and
that's why you know - going back this
original question when does it stop it
stops when the problems get solved did
again just one of those critical
elements which actually is more
important when you think about it the
solving the problem part of it more so
then it's my fault it's their fault or
whatever because if we didn't have this
instinctual blaming self or what it
called defensive defensive mechanisms
yeah that it it wouldn't it just be way
different so but since that is a natural
thing it's kind of like it has to be
part of extreme ownership you know it
just has to be for you to be compelled
to solve the problem if you believe like
for real believe not yes if you if you
if I just go oh this is my fault
and that's it and I don't really believe
that I can solve the problem it's like
this I'm one of one of the guys National
Home Front was talking to a client the
other day and one of the senior people
look one of the senior executives said
you know oh I've got you know 1200
people that work for me I can't be
responsible for what they do when they
make a mistake mmm and here's the deal
when you have that attitude you're right
you can't do anything and this goes back
you know I talked about it with Darrell
Cooper on the Abu Ghraib thing if the
leadership says you know what the gut
the people that are in the prison that
are guarding the the insurgents that
were captured if they do something if
they abuse those prisoners that's not on
me
that's that's somebody on the front line
if you have that attitude then yeah
you're gonna have problem if you have
the attitude hey what happens on the
front line is my responsibility then
guess what you do you clarify your
commanders intent you make sure that
everyone understand what the rules of
engagement are you make sure that owners
everyone understands what the goal of
having these people in these situations
are you making sure they understand what
happens if they get caught or or yeah
what happens if they get caught abusing
prisoners what that's gonna look like
what that's gonna do the war effort you
do all these things to mitigate that
that's what you do but when you think
well you know of course I'm responsible
but I'm not really response yeah you
don't take the actions necessary empty
of ownership to solve those problems and
then when something does go wrong if you
throw up your hands and I can't control
what's happening on frontline I'm firing
you immediately I'm firing you in ten
seconds if I if someone happens the
front line and I talked to the leader
and I say you know your frontline people
did X Y & Z wrong and they go hey you
know what I can't control what's happen
on the frontline I'm like cool you're
fired
you know what I mean like you if that's
your attitude I want something that says
hey you know what here's the things that
I'm implementing make sure that doesn't
happen again here's the course I'm
running here's the oversight I'm putting
in here you know X Y Z to solve those
problems that's what I'm gonna do and I
go okay great you're obviously taking
ownership of the problem I'll take you
no I'm gonna take ownership maybe I can
provide you this or that to help you but
then the once it gets there that that
problem doesn't continue on indefinitely
we get it solved that's the beauty of
extreme ownership is that the problem
gets solved so you're so when you fire
that or you know theoretically it's kind
of like you're firing them because like
you the example you just said right
there with the guy who has that attitude
right no control this you finally
because he's gonna continue to either
allow or be a problem that's gonna
continue yes it's gonna come to anything
so like getting rid of him replacing
whatever that essentially solves a root
of a problem yes bigger problem so what
do you know cuz every once in a while
you'll find it situation coming in
whatever we're in they'll fire digests
as punishment like the it's not
necessarily that given the circumstance
where he'll continue to be a problem
it's not
kind of situation or it doesn't it's not
obvious that it's that kind of situation
but it's like we need someone's head for
this mistake like that kind stuff or
whatever like how would you like I don't
know how would you approach take extreme
ownership does not prevent you from
getting fired yeah we should be
perfectly clear about that I will tell
you that in my opinion you have a better
chance of not getting fired if you take
ownership than if you put your hands up
and put or point fingers and other
people either you put your hands up say
well there's nothing I could do about
that was the front lines that's not me
I'm firing you if you say well it wasn't
my fault it was the a junior leader that
directed that oh are so are you gonna
fire that leader or are you gonna train
them are you gonna do something
different are you gonna implement some
standard operating procedures that can
happen or are you just saying you can't
control it because if you can't control
it I don't need you here so yes
sometimes people take ownership and
they're getting fired anyways I will say
this if they are proactively really
truly taking ownership of what is
happening if they're taking pre-emptive
ownership they're not gonna be sitting
in that position in the first place
because whatever things are unfolding
they go men if we get caught doing that
I'm gonna be the one responsible for it
I own this and so hey frontline you
can't do that here's the training here's
the right protocol here's that here's
how you handle those situations and
don't ever do that again and they go
okay and now when the boss comes to me
and says hey we had this just flare-up I
go yeah here's what I did about it I
know I'm aware of what's happening I
already got it under wraps boss okay
cool thanks but if I go well you know
all that stuff was happening and I never
did anything about it and I didn't know
about it guess what expect to get fired
extreme ownership does not prevent you
from getting fired is it post mortem you
know you caused a problem you allowed a
problem happen under your command you
have a better chance of not getting
fired if you take ownership of it but if
you have an egregious thing happen and
it's on your watch you might get fired
and if you make excuses if you think you
can kind of weasel your way out of it
you're you're good you're gonna get
fired as well you're just gonna look
like a weasel I mean I have this vision
of the guy you know gets fired right in
on his way out his is what are you
calling like a little basket of his
stuff you know that classic image yeah
and he's like what I took
my ownership but I took it yeah you
should have taken extreme ownership
prior to this happening and look yeah
actually it's funny okay remember to say
no how extreme ownership is always on
the top right like no matter the problem
even that let's say I got fired like I
guess I took extreme ownership it was my
fault fully believe did everything and
then I got fired still right meanwhile
I'm like mad at extreme ownership
promoters who didn't work got fired
aren't you sort of blaming extreme
ownership now yes you're the strange in
a strange world you are correct
yeah you're you're now blaming extreme
ownership oh but what you're really
doing is you're you're trying to take
ownership after the fact that's why it's
important to have the attitude of
extreme ownership you that's the problem
within this what I wrote about in
leadership strategy and tactics the
problem with extreme ownership is that
it's post mortem it's after the fact
pre-emptive ownership is hey you take
ownership of everything that's going on
so you prevent these problems from
occurring
yeah now if they occur I will promise
you the best thing you can do is say
here's the problem here's the mistakes I
made here's one ready to fix it
that is your best method of survival and
if you don't do that well if you do that
it's not-- Ladd's I just said it's no
guarantee that you're not gonna get
fired because you still might get fired
but if you run in there and you make a
bunch of excuses I mean yeah okay check
next question chuckle heard general
mattis say that he looks for initiative
and aggressiveness in NCOs I'm not a
naturally aggressive leader do you
believe leaders should be aggressive by
nature when when to be aggressive or
when do you be aggressive does it come
off as fake if not if it's not natural
so you know obviously this is something
we talk about all the time is that deef
being default aggressive is good for
leaders yes that is a true statement
there's a dichotomy obviously because
you can be too aggressive and then
things go wrong and things go bad and
things don't work and yes there are some
people that are let's say more
aggressive by Nature
and then lest also let's also remember
that being aggressive means a lot more
than just being loud brash and
in-your-face right that is the
stereotypical thing that we think of
when we think of all that guys really
aggressive if you think this guy's
in-your-face she's yelling he's you know
pushing people over that is not the type
of aggressiveness that you need to be an
effective leader you don't need to be a
loudmouth you don't need to be brash
don't need to get in people's faces what
being aggressive means is is taking
action that's the kind of aggressiveness
that I'm talking about that's the kind
of aggressive that general mattis is
talking about and you know the
definition actually wrote this down the
definition of of aggressive or one of
the - definitions of being aggressive is
forceful and sometimes overly assertive
pursuit of one's aims so first of all
forceful we get right sometimes overly
assertive some means sometimes that you
have to go a little bit like harder and
here's why that's important because
listen in combat
almost nothing will happen the way you
want it to if you don't force it that
way right you are coming against a
powerful force the enemy nature time
there's all kinds of things that that
are going against you it's a losing
battle and if you don't use force of
will then then then you're not gonna get
it done you have to be aggressive and
make things happen I remember us so
there was a there was we all got
interviewed after we came home from
Ramadi and I remember I was listening to
Seth stone get interviewed and it was
just they were just trying to you know
capture whatever information moments
historical accounts of what had happened
in Ramadi and and Seth said something
along the lines of every operation we
did you could feel jaakko beating his
head against the wall to make things
happen
hey Nana like you know of course I
laughed but from his perspective and
it's a good perspective and it's an
accurate perspective
none of this nothing just kind of oh
that fell into my lap that just doesn't
happen it doesn't happen in combat it
just doesn't happen in combat and so yes
this idea that you're gonna be
aggressive is is is very important but
if you think to yourself well okay okay
look I'm not the type of person that
likes to be a loudmouth likes to shout
likes to yell cool
good it doesn't matter you don't need to
be that way what it means is is you need
to make things happen that's what it
means and it can be this is the good
thing about being aggressive sure
there's there's certain parts of your
nature that are aggressive but it can
also be trained you can you can start to
think with an aggressive mindset which
is I am going to take action I'm gonna
overcome obstacles I'm gonna push
through roadblocks I'm not gonna take no
for an answer and those are things that
you can train and and and how do you
train them look when you when you hit an
obstacle you look at it you you know you
shake your head and you go cool let's go
let's figure this out there's so often
times where people they get told no or
they hit an obstacle in it's game over
for they're just done they're done
training they're over it and your
attitude you have to go okay
little little robot cool how am I gonna
get through it how am I getting around
it and I used to put people so to train
people to be more aggressive regardless
of what their and believe me I had I had
guys you know steel officers that were
coming through that or steel Chiefs that
were coming through real real passive
guys quiet guys you know not the type of
person that you would figure oh that
guy's oh yeah that guy's aggressive you
wouldn't characterize him as that but I
would so what I would do is put them in
situations where if they didn't make
aggressive decisions to make things
happen they were gonna get annihilated
put them in training scenarios like that
okay oh you want to sit here and you
want to wait like you're getting
attacked and you want to sit here in you
want away you don't make it one don't
want to make a decision cool in in 16
minutes I will have everyone in your
task unit dead we will kill them all the
paintball if you and and so they learned
that and I go what do you think happened
you know and they'd say oh we started to
get surrounded and I go and what did you
do well you know we we held position
okay how how long do you hold position
for oh we held it for awhile and what
did the enemy do well they started to
maneuver and then what you do well we
held position and then what the enemy do
well they maneuvered more and then what
you do I held position and we started
taking casualties and then the enemy
maneuvered and then they closed the
distance and then they took us out okay
what do you think would have been better
well perhaps when it first started
before they had us enveloped
I could have made a maneuver to get to
another building with some more high
ground that sounds like a great idea
next time why don't you be a little bit
more aggressive in making things happen
okay put them in the same scenario they
get a little bit more aggressive they
realize that it's that it it serves its
function and they start to develop the
attitude they start to understand what a
lack of aggression will get you because
that's an important thing to know right
it's not just a carrot it's the stick
cool if I do if I do this aggressive
thing it'll be rewarding if I don't do
something aggressive we're gonna get
annihilated so here's the other thing
that you got to be ready for so if
you're if you're a person that you lean
towards being passive you've got to
start to lean towards being aggressive
and here's the thing that you got to
remember you're gonna make mistakes
because when you're aggressive you're
taking more risk in often you're taking
more risk now when you if you've played
out the whole matrix of being passive
burst versus being aggressive I will
tell you that being aggressive is the
one that ends up on top are there but
there are scenarios where your
aggressiveness ends up costing you a
little bit that absolutely happens it
happens in business it happens in life
it happens on the battlefield but
overall being aggressive is what this is
why this is why that this is where the
idea of you this is where the idea of
aggressive has to be your default mode
this is exactly why aggression has to be
your default mode your default mode is
aggressive if your default mode is
aggressive and it's not the right answer
you just usually use the other answer
right
your default mode is aggressive that's
why I originally said to these young
seal officers your default mode has to
be aggressive so if you're not sure if
you should stay as you go go to the
default which is gonna be aggressive
because nine times out of ten seven
times out of ten eight times out of ten
that's gonna be a better move than
sitting on your ass and doing nothing
that's what's gonna get you killed
so your default mode is to go now do you
always go with your default mode no no
you don't always go with it to the
default mode but occasionally you go oh
you know what I'm not gonna go the
default mode you put it you pull the
setting out and you go into the other
mode customize it yeah you customize a
little bit for that particular situation
but your default mode is I'm gonna be
aggressive and that's the the odds you
want the odds you want to stack the odds
in your favor hmm what is it Jason Jason
Gardner says puts it kind of a cool like
good way to just really wrap your head
around like being it default mode
something along the lines of like it's
easier it's better to like have to pull
someone back totally then have to push
them forward yes it's a million times
easier to have to pull the reins in on
someone on an element on a team on a
leader on a person it's a it's a million
times easier to go hey hey come on back
you're going too hard it then going hey
you need to get out there yeah because
by the way I mean if you think about
this from like an actual event unfolding
if an event unfolds and you're the
person that's on point
and you don't react to it properly that
that event needs to make it through you
to me before I can now assess what I
think you should do and then tell you to
go do it and then kick you in the ass so
you go do it I don't want that we
already lost yeah I want I want you to
go hey oh we just got this event started
unfolding I'm on it and you look back at
me hey Jocko I'm solving this problem
right now oh what's the problem right I
don't even know what the problem is yet
you already solving it that's what I
want and if I happen to occasionally
have to pull the reins on you I'm more
than happy to pull the reins on
what so yes that's a universal it's
easier to lead someone that you have to
pull the reins on then you have to push
we'd rather pull back then push forward
and that that idea of being aggressive
is as part of that so I want all my I
want on all my support leaders to be
aggressive and as a leader I know that
my supporters are going to make mistakes
while they're learning to be aggressive
and even when they're being aggressive
and I'm therefore considered fully
trained and fully ready they're still
gonna make mistakes I'm still gonna make
mistakes being aggressive I'm gonna make
mistakes but we're gonna play the odds
and the odds are the odds are you'd be
aggressive I'm trying to think of a good
blackjack you know be you ever play
blackjack before yes sir yeah so I mean
like there's you know dealer's showing
uh whatever do you need to do is showing
twenty and you're showing a fourteen you
got to hit it like that that's the odds
the odds are you got to hit it mm-hmm
dealer's showing a 14 and you're showing
a 14 you gotta let the you gotta you got
to hold let the dealer let the dealer
take the hit do they call it
I forget what do they call it showing
twenty cuz you know one is down one is
up yeah do they call that showing twenty
of a Tanner yeah yeah because you don't
know what the other card is you just
assume like you assume that it's a so
you showing plenty okay yeah and I
haven't played blackjack in a while I
can't I can't believe I'm like
struggling with my thought process
around blackjack around the numbers it
was more of a terminology yeah but you
play the odds
yeah and there's rules when you're
playing the odds in blackjack there's
rules of yeah what you hit and what you
don't and you stick with the rules the
odds are gonna be in your side yeah yeah
more than if you don't if you just sit
back and that's and so we're playing the
odds
we're playing the odds with leadership
yeah and the odds are you default mode
it's not that you never come out of
default mode the odds are you be
aggressive so back to this question
you're listening to another couple
things in this question when to be
aggressive look the default mode is be
aggressive and sometimes you look at it
you'll know now's not
time does it come off as fake or not
natural hey it's not being aggressive
from this perspective isn't how you're
acting it's the decisions that you're
making
it's the decision I was working with a
client yesterday and we were talking
about data I think it was a client call
it was another yeah it was about data
and it was actually this very similar
question hey um I'm not very aggressive
and I'm more of a data guy and I like
numbers and that's how I roll
and yet I'm not getting recognized I was
like cool get aggressive with your data
put your data together and present it up
the chain of command not to say hey look
at me but to say hey here's what's going
on here's what I'm doing you're being
aggressive with your data you're showing
them what's happening cuz the guy wasn't
getting the recognition that he needed
right any was so that meant his senior
leadership didn't know what he was doing
which meant he's not getting the
resources that he needs to do his job
and instead of being like hey this is
what I need because he's not an
aggressive guy he's sitting back and
just getting resources stripped away
from him I said cool you're a data guy
record the data of what you're doing
present it and the dad let the data
speak it default aggressive with your
data did I miss anything here yeah so
it's not natural yeah I mean I mean if
you all of a sudden start to try and act
yeah you know this this new way yeah
it's it's it's probably not gonna go
good now can you do you sometimes have
to learn like okay you know what I gotta
stand up and say something I gotta put
word out right yeah you know and I watch
many guys in my career go through the
transition of being a little bit less
aggressive and they realize you know
what I'm in charge of this thing I gotta
go put the word out and and that's
perfectly fine yeah yeah those kind of
for lack of better term superficial
personality traits that are aggressive
some people say oh well that's that's
aggressive you know where there's more
depth to it
we're like because again like you know
you can think of like a I don't know
some fictional or maybe not in fact not
fictional like maybe Japanese business
tycoon who doesn't say nothing really no
but you know he's making aggressive
moves like that's an aggressive guy kind
of it goes deep
and then you know die who you are you're
saying like he yells and screams and has
a loud voice or whatever it's kind of
okay if that's your personality that's
gonna land for sure but it's more about
the decisions you make even say it's
gonna land what do you mean because that
might just make a bunch of people Hank
right right some toil depends on what
you're yelling and screaming yeah sure
what you're saying is there could be
someone that's loud at scream but
they're but they're they're using that
to cover the fact that they're actually
not making any move essentially but you
see yeah so the yelling and screaming
has very little do with aggressive
movement on the battlefield
yeah he's what you're saying oh I'm
saying there's more depth to it but the
point actually is is that um you should
have just taken that point cuz that was
a good point he's gonna take it out was
wrong with it but I want to continue
this was a probably less chlorophyll but
nonetheless if you if because he's
concerned about faking it or coming off
as fing where if you're focused on those
like a superficial elements of your
personality being aggressive that's the
part they're gonna smell is fake if
you're trying to change that part of
sure you know like oh just probably used
to have this tea in seventh grade news I
don't know I think it's like a music
teacher Oh something super aggressive
mutant ultra he was like a nice dude
like really nice there's not too many
stereotypical hyper aggressive music
teachers no man he wasn't I had I had an
assistant platoon commander and
aggressive great guy and he you know I
didn't I you know as I got to know him
you know and it was like so would you
study in college and he's like
percussion yeah dang it were you talking
about I was like what concussion why
he's like percussion drumming user draw
he started drumming in college which is
just kind of deep and percussion yeah I
didn't know you could major in
percussion I mean I guess
but anyways history of percussion yeah
properties of percussion my point is had
he become a music teacher
he would probably little bit because use
the rest of the system platoon commander
yeah had if I had to pull the reins on
him
we'll be out there getting after it this
guy was not aggressive at all he was
like a nice guy trying to please
everyone you know short term and long
term kind of thing which didn't really
work with FA I'm pretty sure was seventh
grade so he was like I remember guys we
just run circles around him you know
like people wouldn't listen and also
he had trouble controlling the class
we'll say that and then I wanted one
time he tried the switches personality
yeah one time he dropped the book you
know how like sometimes when you drop a
book yes sometimes when he hits
correctly it's like boom it's like a
fire so one time Brad he tried to do
that and it didn't make the sound and
like no one it was like what the fuck is
this guy doing he's like looking
everybody with his eyes all big
nonetheless I think that was like I
think he got aggressive one day and
people like shut up and we're like hey
this guy's like you know how on
someone's never aggressive then they
start yelling you're like everyone kind
of B's quietly Ang's cuz yelling so I
think he might have got a small little
payoff one day and then from then on he
started to try to be like aggressive
when everyone could smell it on like
Brad that's not even your thing so he's
gotta be working against them yeah
everyone was kind of laughing at him now
he's like a weirdo yep so no no no no
need to do that no no we throw in the
music book on the table
big textbook is on the floor too yeah it
didn't work for CH next question so this
question is actually that I got one of
them that I got from EF online so EF
online you know since the big lockdown
in the world we've pushed a lot of
resources and time and effort in the EFM
on it was actually something that we
were working on so it's good timing but
EF online used to be a relatively static
training platform really aimed at
enterprise clients so big companies
would train their people based on the
leadership principles and but it's it's
a powerful tool and so with the lockdown
we've wouldn't work on a lot of our
clients through webinars so what we've
basically we've we've we've really kind
of we formulate reformulated and our
reott aking this online world and so
what we do so we're doing a bunch of
live webinars we're doing Q&A sessions
we got chats going on we got we've got a
forum so we got all kinds of things that
are happening what it's doing is it's
now it's got we got like a community of
people that
on there all the time they're asking us
questions we're just it's just awesome
and so one of the questions that I got
asked was from a from a police officer
who was basically talking about he's got
some complainers or he was talking about
one complainer in particular and the
question was what advice do you have for
dealing with that one officer on your
team that is the Debbie Downer they
complain about everything you know the
one no matter what you ask the team to
do that one guy or gal that sucks all
the energy out of the room
the buzzkill so I thought that this was
a good question and I thought it was a
good question because everybody knows
that there's a everybody knows that
person so much that there's a term for
it debbie downer
right there's an existing a pre-existing
term for that person that's complaining
and being a being negative about
everything so a couple and what's cool
what's really cool about doing this
stuff online is now you know right now
I'm reading the question when I'm doing
this work where the person is they're
like we're talking faces I mean it's not
face to face but it's face to face cuz
you're on the interwebs and I'm looking
right at the person they're looking
right at me and so it's very cool you're
having a conversation you know the one
thing that's negative about the this
podcast is well it's us reading our best
interpretation of a question through the
interwebs
whereas EF online you can they can
clarify you can talk you can get details
and it it makes it really makes it
really cool so so so so back to this
question debbie downer so leadership
strategy and tactics I talked about what
one of the solutions that I have for a
lot of different leadership problems is
actually putting people in charge so you
put somebody in charge of the of a
mission of a project of a task and they
want to complain about it cool they can
complain about themselves because
they're the one that's running it so
that's that's one option
and that that option works a lot right
sometimes it might not work sometimes it
might not be feasible
you know you can't take maybe a junior
person and put them in charge of a giant
project because it's just you you the
way the responsibility has been doled
out from the chain of command it you're
not allowed to put you know private
Jackson sir in charge or or private
debbie downer in charge of something so
here's another and this is another
option that another thing that you can
do and this is a really incredibly
brilliant solution mmm-hmm listen to him
right
actually listen to what they have to say
so sometimes people complain because
they complain so much no one actually
ever listens to them and they just keep
doing it and it has no impact the only
impact that it has is it gives them a
little good feeling because they got to
put up a little protest right they gotta
just throw a little shot a little- shot
at the hole at the man at the system at
the mission at the bar they just throw
this little complaint out and look it's
it's it's kind of within the rules right
like you're it's no one it's it's almost
bad to say hey don't want to hear any
complaints right so you complain and you
get away with it yeah so so that's what
they do they've got to get this
passive-aggressive little complaining
going on so one thing you can do is
actually listen to what they say
actually say oh you know what that go
actually good ok can you meet me after
this meeting I want to actually dig down
and see what you're talking about
all of a sudden they're thrown for a
loop just that right there I can solve
the problem and then when they comment
when you talk to him actually write down
what they are talking about so those are
two solution things and then you know
again cuz EF online is live and I'm
actually talking to the person that's
asking me this question so you know I
said hey what's going on and I started
digging out digging into it a little bit
and the complaint was a was again this
is a police department the complaint was
about the current mission that was
happening mm-hmm and the mission that
they had been the mission that his squad
had been in charge of had been shifted
and this person was that's main thing
that
this person was complaining about why we
doing this this is to beat someone else
blah blah blah blah and you know it was
a hard mission and then as I'm talking
to the leader the leader actually says
look well you know I didn't like the
mission either so think about that and
just think about that the leader didn't
like the mission and one of the
subordinates is complaining about it and
I'm saying of course you're gonna have
complete people complaining about the
mission you don't even like the mission
hmm you don't even like the mission and
now you're surprised that some of your
subordinate and one in particular that
always complains anyways it's
complaining about something that you
don't even like yeah so you know here's
the deal like I said talk to the
complainer write down their complaints
and then actually give some responses or
reasons that explain why things are
happening the way they are happening
it's actually give explanations for what
that individual is complaining about and
by the way if you don't have good
explanations then go get them go up your
chain of command and say hey boss here's
what's going on you know this is what
we're this is what some of my troops are
saying and I agree with these parts can
we get some explanations behind this so
it's like um when we got to Ramadi
you're gonna be working with Iraqi
soldiers I got all kinds of complaints
about that out of the gate and as I've
said many times before I was the chief
complainer for about three minutes
before I said okay why are we actually
doing this let me think about this and I
didn't have to ask this up in my chain
of command cuz I figured out why we were
doing it it was what we needed to do to
win the war and so then I was able to
explain you want to complain cool I
accept your complaint I agreed with it a
minute ago
here's the solution I came to here's the
answer here's why we're doing this and
all of a sudden the complaints are going
to go down and then if you've got people
that are complaining about things you
give them the answer and you'll move
forward that's why I don't look at
complaining as a negative thing
necessarily
and by the way if complaining is
happening and I let it continue happen
whose fault is that is it Debbie downers
fault
it kinda no no I almost just hooked a
knife at you yeah and the feet feels
like it that's why he's gonna be like oh
yeah I can't believe Gabby down right
all you gotta do is not complain
yeah just shuffle don't wait no actually
I own this oh one of my subordinates is
complaining okay cool how can I solve
this how about we figure out research
what the complaints are about and not
only does it stop them from complaining
but I'm actually building relationships
with the team because I'm being
responsive to what their complaints are
and when I do that I make the team
tighter and I make the operational
capability of the team higher and now we
can do a better job accomplishing our
mission so when you get a complainer try
listening to what the complaints are you
can try putting them in charge you can
give them explanations as to why the
things are they're complaining about
aren't happening because if I got my
team complaining I'm gonna assume that
there's some validity to it and if
there's no validity to it
well then cool you come to me with a
complaint that's completely invalid and
I show you oh oh yeah here's why your
complaints invalid because this this and
this so now you're complaining about
something that is not true right
you're not gonna continue down that road
no I didn't realize that boss or you're
gonna say well if that's true Boston why
what about this and I go okay let me let
me figure that one out for you I'm not
sure yeah yeah kind of goes along with
like how you'd say like when you pull
the thread you know mm-hmm like the
beginning of that thread is just the
complaint all right but when you start
pulling the thread all the way out it's
kind of like oh sure there's some valid
stuff in here but uh in a different
situation it could be that yeah this
guy's just a complainer this answers to
all of this stuff there that may be like
I don't know maybe it's his laziness or
is whatever like all invalid complaints
when you pull out that thread it's like
you can see that too right yeah there
could be valid it could be invalid yeah
pull the thread find the answer to that
and to and give it to ya listening the
lien the most underrated tool of
leadership now your ears but you can
kind of I mean it's not like soap like
ludicrous though like to dismiss a
complainer it's not that because you
know like how you said everyone knows a
debbie downer
and man after a while the complaint can
be valid or invalid it's come an you
just but you just complain so much you
just dismiss them already you know
literally like a Debbie died I'm
thinking lot yes but the only way to
break them of that they've gotten into
that habit because their complaints
don't have any they don't have any they
don't have they don't have any outcome
they don't have any result the only
thing ours a little a little uh yeah a
little pay what's that what's that thing
it'll dopamine hit when I say this is
the dumbest mission we've ever done and
and that's it
it just makes me feel good everyone hurt
me you know everyone knows that I think
this is dumb and now I'm just gonna
continue going through the motions of
whatever but I'm being negative I'm
trying the people down but at least I
got mine yes and and the habit forms
that yeah and you can break that habit
when someone goes all this is the
dumbest mission of ever seen oh hey hey
I could what what part of the mission do
you think is dumb let me you want what
part oh well I think your mom let me get
my notebook and write and write this
down what do you got you know it's
another on EF online I've been doing
these um leadership primers of saying
like hey here's a little thing that
here's a little thing to think about
right when you when you for the reason I
use this word leadership primer mmm
so Hackworth has a book called Vietnam
primer get people ready to it was
written in like whatever 60 68 when guys
were getting ready to go to Vietnam and
so he wrote Vietnam primer to give them
a heads up get them mind right give them
some good tips for for how that to be
ready to deploy well think about this
think if think if you were walking to
your house and there was a bad guy in
there a criminal had broken in and he
and as soon as you walked in he he you
know threw a punch at you or he ran at
you or he was not gonna he when you
walked in he's confronting you yeah
think if ten seconds before you walked
in you got the message that said hey
when you walk in here there's a bad guy
in your house you're you would respond
way better so the leadership primer EF
online the leadership primer is just me
saying hey here's a little something
about today here's a little something to
put you and one of the leadership
primers I did the other day was get a
notebook get a notebook a little
notebook keep it in your pocket when
somebody tells you something up the
chain or down the chain of command get
out your notebook and write it now yeah
you know how I met how powerful that is
think of it if you think of it from
either direction think of your mind
subordinate and you tell me something
and I get out my notebook and write it
down what are you thinking yeah cares
yep
now what if you're my boss and you say
hey joko can you take care of XYZ no yes
no problem sir I get out my notebook and
write it down let me take it now your
initial thought it's like of course it's
positive I actually have to follow
through I can't just like take notebooks
and throw them away right so you have to
actually take your notes and log them
down but that's a little that's a little
tool that you can use you wouldn't be
able to get when I was in the times when
all the games you won't be able to find
me without a notebook you would not be
able to find me without a notebook and
by the way I have a good memory too I
have a good memory doesn't matter when
you tell me something I'm gonna write it
down because I hey I don't want to
forget it and B I want you to know that
I got you and you know it's cool three
weeks goes by and I go hey echo you
remember you're asking me about this
piece of gear that you thought we should
have here's the research we actually
have more dirt you know what I'm saying
boom or you're my boss and I say hey
boss three weeks ago you mentioned this
to me off-the-cuff you said you wanted
to know how many guys I had called for
this thing and how me we're gonna have
ready for deployment I just want to let
you know the numbers 12 right now and
I'm gonna have 17 when we go on
deployment yeah and the boss goes so
what does that mean does that mean I'm
kissing my boss's ass about no means
first of all he had a reason for asking
me that and second of all his trust in
me just went up a little bit in both
directions yeah so that's the point here
when someone starts complain
to you look let's face it a lot of time
these complaints they're throwaway
comments yeah and obviously you're not
letting get thrown away oh yeah you're
getting out the notebook yeah so little
leadership primer and carry a notebook
with you
something happens write it down and
actually you know you could say yeah you
don't you just get out your phone and go
into the notes thing I'm but I kind of
don't agree with that
let's face it when people pull out their
phone unless you go hold on you know you
if you're gonna pull your phone and make
a note in your phone you gotta tell them
what you're doing you got a sec hold on
a second let me let me let me write that
let me put that in my notes because
otherwise they think oh cool I'm telling
him a major problem off gandhi's day
he's shooting a text in the ground so
yes listen to your compile listen when
people have complaints listen dig down
pull the thread put them in charge
that's an option but also listen to pull
the thread dig down find the solution
find the reason and explain it to him ya
know taking thing I can't help but and
this is just an extreme version of and
so which I think you kind of like almost
implied a little bit there where you
know how like on the movie I don't know
which one all of them I don't know you
have the little you know you have the
powerful boss walking around in the
little o ya know tape taking everything
writing every little thing down you know
kind of thing don't be that guy writing
everything down you know because this
it's kind of like brothers guys just
know you know we're actually writing
down positive things right now I guess a
complaints not a positive thing but it's
positive that you're saying oh wait a
second there's a problem there's
something you don't understand cool yeah
yeah important stuff yeah you know and
it almost goes back to like opening your
mouth to begin with you know like you
only say important stuff don't just blah
blah blah I'm simply with the
note-taking almost kind of thing where
if you're this especially if you're a
subordinate write notes and also let me
make this perfectly clear you're not
taking notes so that you can prove to
them that you're listening you take
notes so you can log down what they're
saying and you can pull the string on it
either direction right that's what
you're doing you're not doing it so Oh
I'm gonna make a good impression no
you're doing it because it's gonna do a
bet it's gonna make you do a better job
so you can better support the guys above
you and below you in the chain of
command so that we can win rather that's
such a good point because that's that
caricature in the movie
who's taking notes you know like the
little taking too many notes I knew guys
that would write things down and never
do anything with them yeah just one I
have less respect for action Yeah right
I spent some smack sure oh yeah but
that's the point right where that's why
that character a character exists in the
movie because he's he's displayed and
shown as a kick kiss-ass guy writing
every little runner and you could tell
that's his whole intention is to be the
kiss-ass it's like to display that you
know kind of thing where and that's what
it comes down to like you're actually in
tension because it's like like you've
always said look man people can smell
that on you if you're like there did if
you have some ulterior motive or
whatever tension has a strong smell you
can quote me on that the intention has a
strong smell and if your intention what
what your intention is will be smelled
by the people around you oh yeah and
that's how it's gonna look it has a lot
- it has a Lingus like the smell is more
pungent in both directions in both
directions by the way yeah my intention
is to take care of you yeah that's that
is felt you know it's smelt and its
pungent if mine if my intention is to
kiss your ass you can smell that just as
well cool yes agree next question this
is gonna sound like a strange question
but how would you advise mentally
preparing for the horrors of war like if
you knew someone you cared about was
going to be on the frontlines what would
you tell them
I would tell them to detach you know I
would tell them to detach I would tell
them to do their job but don't get all
caught up in it because that's what you
have to do you if you go in the front
lines and and you know right now there's
a bunch of doctors and nurses going on
the front lines and hospitals and that
can be emotionally overwhelming look
they do that for a living but when you
see overcrowded or whatever's happening
you could see where people might be
overwhelmed by that or their health at
risk so they're overwhelmed by that so
do your job but you got to stay detached
from it don't get all caught up in it
and also I would say I would tell him
look it's it's oh it the the emotions
that you're gonna have are okay and it's
normal you're gonna feel scared you're
gonna feel disgusted you're gonna feel
horrified you're gonna feel sick all
those things are all those things are
normal they're normal feelings that
you're gonna have when you are seeing
this side of humanity for the first time
I would say I would tell them to write
down and talk about what they see what
they hear what they feel with other
people because if you try and keep them
contained inside your own head you won't
process them as well when you write
things down it forces you to think
through them when you talk about with
other people you get some of that out of
your system so I think that's powerful
separate work from home right so you're
gonna go in this horrible place don't
bring that home with you how do you do
that change out of your uniform get to
put you put you put your flip-flops on
put your put your shorts on and your
t-shirt when you get home don't wear
your uniform don't wear your police
uniform don't wear your your doctors
don't wear your scrubs home take them
off
don't wear your EMT uniform home don't
just don't do that change and then
compartmentalize because you do you got
to compartmentalize these bad things and
and I guess maybe that could be
construed in a negative way
like I'm saying
knock down you know hi come put them in
a compartment and put away I'm not
saying that I'm saying separate because
I because what I'm saying I'm not saying
lock things we'll put things in a box
and lock them there I'm not saying that
at all I'm actually saying the opposite
right about them talk about them with
your friends you know talk about what
you experienced where you felt all that
stuff it's gonna make you feel better
but keep it separate from people that
don't have that experience right so you
don't want to drag home the war to your
wife and your kids you don't want to
drag home the the ER to your wife and
your kids you don't want to drag home
the perpetrators and the horrible things
you see as a police officer you don't
wanna drag those home every day mmm so
compartmentalize and I think those are
the things that I've done that mmm
that I think it felt me all right this
next question do you mind if I read this
next question I don't mind this next
question is kind of it's a good question
I think we're gonna get a lot out of it
but it's a lot it's a little bit of a
longer question and I'm gonna actually
end up a reading and I think twice first
someone's gonna read it through here we
go I've been working on asking you this
question for over a year and this is the
best way I can I think I can articulate
it everything I say falls on deaf ears I
try to give advice when a stir if
someone is in trouble and they don't
listen to the sound advice then later I
try to get them listen to someone else
that might have more credibility an
author or podcaster philosopher etc and
they still won't listen they tried their
hardest to make what solutions I'm
trying to give don't not apply to them
because of X Y & Z all excuses almost as
if they are too good to implement the
advice because it came from me and me
alone
literally solving people's problems and
they are deliberately not listening it's
not how I present the information they
should use my tonality is just
fine it's almost as if they won't listen
because they know I'm right and I want
to prove and they want to prove I'm
wrong by not giving me the respect I
feel the majority of people see me as
lesser not worthy of respect or
listening to even though I use such
obvious logic these people continuously
try to exercise power over me
defiantly an extreme non influential
presence even with logic tact
respectfulness no one wants to listen to
me people just refuse to even
respectfully move out of the way when
I'm trying to get around them not even
strangers people I live with I don't
understand what it is about me that most
people don't respect everyone seems to
have the attitude to defy or oppose
everything I say no matter the
circumstances whether I'm trying my best
to lead give advice etc people won't
listen to me they won't get behind me I
lack so much influence it's not funny I
try but to no avail what do you think so
look it's it's a it's it's it's a rough
situation right yes like I feel for the
individual in that situation I feel I
think I imagine the frustration that you
feel being in that position where you're
just no one's listening to you that
being said you know we have a situation
here where you can see a lot of it is
based on everyone else's problems and
not mine so it starts off everything I
say falls on deaf ears so even even that
statement right there even that
statement right there out of the gate
it's not well it's not what I'm saying
it's that they are deaf correct yeah so
that right there's this we're opening
opening salvo is you're not listening to
me
then I try to give advice when asked or
if someone is in trouble and they don't
listen to sound advice again whose fault
is that
I'm giving you sound advice and even
every nots they're not listening
continues on then I try to get them to
listen to someone else that might have
more credibility an author or podcaster
philosopher and they still won't listen
and I'm sitting there thinking myself I
wonder what that sounds like
right I imagine that it sounds something
like you know you should pack Worth says
the exact same thing is me or or uh you
know you might want to listen to some
Sam Harris because if you listen some
Sam Harris used to some Tim Ferriss
you'll see the light on this meaning I'm
over here I already see the light you
know you might want to you might want to
check out the light with me or you know
Marcus Aurelius is a Minoan of the
classic Stoics you might want to check
him out
so I feel like there's a little you know
you're just bolstering your opinion by
offering other people that that that you
agree with mm-hm and now it's supposed
to give it clout it's kind of a feeling
I get a little bit okay
continue on then they try their hardest
to make what solutions I'm trying to
give doesn't apply to them because of X
Y Z all excuses and again
now instead of saying hey well what way
am i explaining these that people have
got perfect solutions allegedly which
again that's a huge that's a huge
assumption is that my solutions are
frickin perfect and they just won't
listen but instead of saying that it's
like oh maybe my solutions number one
aren't that great or number two maybe
I'm not explaining them out very well
but none of this is my fault it's their
fault and it's making excuses that it's
not on me and then it continues almost
as if they are too good to implement the
advice because it came from me and me
alone and and this is where you start to
hear that it's worse sir I start to get
a little bit of a sense of the mindset
of the individual because the
individuals perception that they don't
and that people don't like or people
don't respect them the individual it
causes them it causes that individual to
act in ways that they that that
individual doesn't even perceive
themselves
mmm-hmm so what shows through again
intent has a smell what shows through is
frustration what shows through is
resentment you know what I'm saying
resentment shows through you can't hide
resentment annoyance when you're annoyed
that people and listen to it shows
through arrogance show when you're when
you think you have the perfect solution
and that's how you're coming across
that's how you're talking people that
shows through mmm
and so although that that perception
that people don't like me that
perception that I'm that that people are
looking down on me that perception that
you have of yourself shows through it it
comes across in a bad way the next
sentence literally solving people's
problems and they are deliberately not
listening again none of this has to do
with me none of it has to do with mices
my solutions themselves none of it has
to do with any of that they just don't
like me it's their fault yeah and by the
way in doing that we have to assume that
these people are just gonna fail because
they're not listening so I would rather
fail than listen to Fred here mm-hmm and
then he can't and then this is just it's
not how I present the information they
should use my tonality is just fine
right yeah right it's not my fault my
tonality is my tonality is fine like the
way I'm presenting look I'm presenting
this in the most just beautiful way yeah
it's not it's not on me it's not my
fault my tonality is actually perfect
the way I present my ideas is so good
you know it's funny it's like I know
you're exaggerating but it's for a good
reason I yeah I try to make the point
yeah
and that's good because you know I'm I'm
putting myself in his shoes where I'm
like my tonality is fine like what do
you what does it feel like when you for
real believe that your tonality is fine
you say but that's fine like but really
what it really is and never never really
thought about it just it doesn't stand
out it's not fine to me you know so it's
like yeah my tone is fine I'm gonna
include that in there just so we all
know kind of thing right that feels for
me yeah in reality it's like oh is it
fine just fine because apparently not
right so that's why you exaggerated it
to help it stand out as a thing you
something but yes thank you that's what
I like too analogies fine that's what I
felt you might as well have said my
tonality is the most perfect tonality in
the history of yeah yeah cuz yeah
because that's not something that you
would even think about yeah yeah you
just be like as a person say yeah but
you go through it you think you know
what the way I talk to everyone is
actually fine it's actually good yeah if
it wasn't I would know about it he asked
Lear to stand out to me yeah exactly
next one next sentence it's almost as if
they won't listen to me because they
know I'm right and they want to prove
I'm wrong by not giving me the respect
all kinds of insecurity issues right
there all kinds of all kinds of
insecurity and that insecurity comes
across and it doesn't come across as
like oh you know echoes kind of insecure
but we'll listen you know it comes
across as you're over compensating by a
long shot and by the way it's almost as
if they won't listen to me because they
know I'm right I mean that's just crazy
talk right how many times echo Charles
how many times have you heard me say I
know I'm right none and and there's some
things that I'm pretty knowledgeable
about yeah right yeah there's some
right about and how many times have I
and I don't know what this I don't even
know what this guy does for a living but
let's say maybe well there's no talent
but even a master of something shouldn't
say I know I'm right
yeah very very very seldom yeah very
seldom it man especially that right
there I know I'm right there's a
difference between like I know this is
true or I know this how about this I
think this is true okay well I'm talking
like because I know in the next level
yeah okay so okay yeah if you want to
say in factual like like he was there he
was that person was there at that
location like I know that that's true
like that's different than saying I know
I'm right about this you know I know I'm
right I know yeah no you have never said
that
meanwhile this guy is saying it and and
by the way you know this is like you
started starting to get into the hey
everyone is against me and know every
like the whole world everyone that I
that I deal with they all don't listen
to me what is wrong with everyone else
right this isn't even like hey look you
and I had a little disagreement I'm
gonna take ownership of it and just say
it's my fault no this is everyone yeah
continuing on I feel the majority of
people see me as lesser not worthy of
respect or listening to even though
listening even though I use such obvious
logic now this is this is where I start
to feel like a sympathy right like cuz
now you got this bad low self-esteem low
self opinion and when you see yourself
as lesser then you start to
overcompensate for it many people start
to overcompensate and you know they
start to try and act like yeah they
start to say things like I use obvious
logic yeah there's a whole genre of
people who like to use the terms facts
logic and and and and so when they say
well you don't want Jellico look I come
at people with facts and logic and
sometimes it just pisses them off in
what they don't you know what I mean
it's it's it's that it's the
it's one of the things that that you say
you refer back to a lot which is when
someone says you know hey I'm just a
Thai person just have to deal it they
feel the same way about saying look I
just deal in facts and logic and you
know people just need to people can't
accept it and what are you gonna say
well you know lies are better or it's
one of those it's kind of like you put
yourself on a you know in a position of
authority right listen I like to use
facts and logic as like irrefutable yeah
I I use facts and logic and other people
are just emotional and crazy and
obviously everyone so just listen to me
so that's kinda that's kind of a a
little bit of that tonality here so it
continues these people and by the way
the people is in quotes okay the people
is in quotes these people as if they're
subhumans yes these people continuously
try to exercise their power over me
defiantly an extreme and then this is
kind of weirdly worded sentence an
extreme non influential presence even
with logic tact and respectfulness so
he's talking about himself no one wants
to listen to me so just saying that you
have tact respectfulness and logic I
mean this is this is there's no
ownership about the message about the
delivery about the tonality about the
attitude everything is everyone else's
fault and by the way like this is one of
those things where if he was talking
about you know I got this one department
and the two senior people in the
department they have a real then you
start thinking okay well you know maybe
they maybe they got some ego and maybe
you need a massage they're either will
work through that this is everyone this
is we're talking about you know everyone
that I'm interacting with doesn't listen
to me
they they disrespect me it continues on
people just refuse to even respectfully
move out of the way when I'm trying to
get around them not even strangers
people I live with this this statement
first of all why not move around other
people right that's first of all second
of all you ever hear when someone says
oh
I was thinking about buying a Corvette
and now everywhere I look I see
Corvettes yeah and this is the same
thing where he feels disrespected now
anytime anybody's in his way
it's their are straight-up disrespecting
him for continues on I don't understand
what it is about me that most people
don't respect everyone seems to have the
attitude to defy or oppose everything I
say no matter the circumstance whether
I'm trying my best to lead give advice
etc people won't listen to me they won't
get behind me I lack so much influence
it's not funny I try but to no avail
what do you think so here's what I think
to this individual
stop trying so hard stop trying so hard
to lead stop trying so hard to influence
stop trying so hard to give advice to
everybody leadership starts with
following people that's how that's not
that's that's where leadership starts I
would say assessing what I'm reading
that you lack real true confidence real
true confidence you have some false
bravado that makes you say it's obvious
and I'm logical that's not real I think
you lack and the the lack of confidence
comes through all over this thing and so
does the overcompensation so oddly
enough let me tell you something start
training jiu-jitsu it's a strange thing
to say right a strange thing to say
start lifting weights those are those
are two things I'm going to say start
training jiu-jitsu start lifting weights
why because you lack confidence and
those things will start to give you
confidence start listening to people
instead of always feeling like you need
to give your two cents
start listing to people it actually
takes confidence to listen right all
right about that in leadership strategy
and tactics it takes extreme like
confidence to accept other people's
ideas that takes the highest level of
confidence and if you don't know that
then you're constantly trying to show
that you don't need to listen their
ideas so start listening to other people
start trying to support their plans
instead of trying to force your great
ideas down everyone's throat because
right now you don't have relationship
with anybody all you do is you your
costly outbound that people do this do
that it's always about you
so start following other people start
supporting other people it takes
confidence takes true confidence to
follow it takes true confidence to
support other people and right now you
don't have that kind of confidence you
don't have that kind of humility and so
you act arrogant and that's that right
there is probably why no one listens to
you because you act arrogant so force
yourself to be humble force yourself to
listen force yourself to follow and over
time you will start to be appreciated
and when people start to appreciate that
you and the way you behave then people
will start to listen to you and then
eventually you can you will be followed
by people and all that right there
starts off with you taking ownership of
your shortfalls instead of blaming
everyone else because that's exactly
what this whole thing is and if you want
to go through life blaming everyone else
for everything that doesn't go your way
then you actually have no power over it
and you'll just continue in this
situation forever but if you want
actually take ownership of it you can
fix the shortfalls which are yours
they're your shortfalls and then you can
become eventually the leader that you
want to be otherwise you continue down
this path of blaming everyone else not
changing yourself then you will continue
to be not listened to not respected
we this is like this is an extreme case
really it's an extreme case it's an
extreme case and I I really hope I mean
I truly hope that this individual is
really listening yeah because the way
that this individual feels about
everyone else is gonna be really rude
Jacques was an idiot yeah another or
another one of those people people yeah
won't listen to my logic yeah and and
it's it makes that actually honestly it
makes me sad it makes me sad to see
someone in this state yeah it does well
there and I don't want to come off like
an extreme case like I'm this like
expert but I will say that well I think
we all are in the same row but you say
speaking American speak we're all in the
same boat to say we know what this is
like we know people like this all the
time
yeah yes like you know I'm not like
disparaging Fitness people at all but
you ever had an extreme Fitness person
where if you ate some bubble gum they'd
be like you know much sugars in that
bubble gum
the thing is bread that's all true all
that facts all those facts and logic and
all this stuff oh yeah they're not gonna
land though because breath okay so I
used to I used to get into arguments but
little things with my brother where he
he'd everyone said well he's not an
extreme case but every once in a while
he'll bust out some debate stuff you
know out of nowhere right where you know
how someone will say something and
they're they're just talking casually
and then you'll be like hey what you
said there's no right and remove you're
all this stuff right yeah no one likes
that no one likes that you no matter how
correct no matter so what what I wound
up telling them to try to sum up the
whole thing I said what you're saying is
right but what you're doing is wrong and
so it's like there's another level to it
and you know like all this facts and
logic whatever we had told that to your
brother yes like when you when you wait
you guys were in a debate of some kind
no you were just give him a general sort
of overview of his existence holding him
before getting people into debates all
the time you know like it mean you're
talking
like there was this time I think this is
what prompted it where me and Terry were
and we were just talking about kids you
know just kind of raising kids and we're
like doing this and this and he was sort
of listening and kind in the
conversation but I was talking to and
he's and we're talking about something I
forget exactly what it was but something
about like how if you do this this will
create this response with the kids and
then we're like but what if it had the
reverse response or whatever and he
chimed in with something like oh no it
would have this initial response and I'm
like well but you could stand to reason
that look they might respond like this
you know kind of just just talking
though like isn't it interesting
anything and then meanwhile I'm talking
to Terry by the way mmm and facilitating
Jade's comments but I'm more talking to
Terry anything he then he interrupts
Anka's no no there's studies about this
and then and then I'm like everyone's
kind of like pause and was like oh he's
really aggressive right now he even said
afterwards it's like I'm sorry that came
off whatever he likes to do that oh yeah
big time and that's why why i hain't
Wanda when I say scolding it's like
brother that's your brother so it's not
even scolding but nonetheless it's yeah
like what you're saying regardless of
what it is like if you're if you have
all these ear a logic irrefutable logic
and facts and all this stuff like
brother it's all correct but what you're
doing is wrong what what just one thing
that really bothers me about this is I
actually know 100% which I just talked
about not saying I know that an
individual in this situation can turn it
around
yes so I know they can turn it around
yes there's a leadership strategy and
tactics I have a section called conform
to influence it just talks about like
hey basically what you just said you
know when the fitness person's like hey
you should work out every day at 4
o'clock in the morning and people are
like hey dude I'm not gonna listen to
you cuz you're barking at me you're
offensive to me yeah you know I had that
I had this question at the muster in
Australia from the female that was like
hey I love health I care about health
I'm working out every morning I'm trying
to get everyone motivated I'm telling
them that they shouldn't be eating what
they're eating for lunch
I'm telling they
you come work out with me afterwards and
she's basically not part of the crew
yeah they're all just looking at her
thinking just be quiet and I said why
don't you form some relationships with
the people so that they start to listen
to you
so that's another kind of overlying to
our underlying tone here is you don't
have relationships with anybody why are
they gonna listen to anything that you
say yeah form relationships with people
how do you do that you listen to them
you follow them you support them yeah
that is like you say that you can
recover from it and that yeah but it's
not gonna be the next day man it's in
fact no no yeah yeah for sure he's got
he's got a little campaign he's got a
campaign a big campaign because the same
way that you look at the Corvette thing
that you do and you're always seeing the
Corvettes everywhere yeah and so it's
like this kind of pattern of thought
right where now he looks at everyone as
like oh I just can't wait like it's
almost like he's waiting for them
anticipating them to disrespect them or
whatever and that's just how but the
same it's a two-way street
people are not waiting for him to say
some BS to them now he's gonna roll in
the room and people like here comes
whatever let this crap let me throw a
hypothesis at you the reason I think it
might be a little not as hard as you
think it would be is because I bet
people don't really have these horrible
feelings about them I bet they're just
you know it's kind of like oh yeah like
when they say oh you know I know when
they say to them I don't think we're
gonna do it that way he's thinking see
they don't listen and they're really
just thinking well it seems like there's
a problem with that you know it seems
like that'd be a little logistically
complicated you know and he doesn't hear
that he just hears they hate me and they
don't listen to me that is possible so
it might not be you know it's I got I
get asked sometimes you know well um you
know I'm a female and and the guys are
thinking this or I'm a man I'm working
these women they're thinking that and I
go you know who probably is thinking the
most about being a man in that room yeah
you you just probably thinking the most
about being a woman you know I've been
taught I've had female leaders come and
brief me over and over again and I'm not
thinking oh it's a woman I'm gonna see
it from this perspective you know are
there some people that do that sure but
most people are like oh it's
what is she talking about so there's a
good chance that all that some of this
is just in his head if some of it is
just in his head and the person that's
thinking about this the most is actually
him yeah it's possible it's also
possible that well I miss this much I
can promise you these people are not
going home and thinking about him all
night yeah I can promise you that's not
happening maybe two of them are yeah
he's going home and thinking about them
all day all night he's thinking about
how much they disrespect him how much
they're not thinking about that they
don't move out of his way he somebody's
you know he walks down the hallway and
wants to get into the the freakin
refrigerator room and someone's in the
way and and you know they kind of like
let go first
yeah they never think about that moment
he's dwelling on it don't dwell on it
man no one's thinking about it
just be this be cool this and other
people be humble that's rough to like if
you if that's in your mind like people
just won't even get out of my way when
I'm trying to go randoms like whoa bro
that's like some sensitive like Brad
that's where you're finding this soup
right you're finding Corvettes
everywhere you wanted Corvettes
everywhere you look is a Corvette even
Corvettes that are Corvettes start
looking like Corvettes you know you
start seeing you know Fieros yeah Fieros
I'm looking like yes unfortunately you
start looking like that Corbin yeah but
and yeah yeah to me as far as me goes
that's true but at the same time
everyone could know this about this guy
everyone could have this like notion of
this guy that this is who this guy is or
any he's so annoying every little thing
that I do he's he has some advice to
make it different or better you know
even those guys you don't think about
them when they're not there well yeah
right yeah even those guys yeah when
they show up you're like oh here comes
Billy yeah with this and somebody named
Bill by the way hit me up on social
media
bill okay so let's say there Darren you
know yeah
you got little Darren coming in Egon
here's Darren with his loud mouth he's
got his own ideas yeah
when Darren leaves I'm not thinking
about Darren it's not driving me crazy
I'm not writing I'm not taking a year he
took a year to formulate this email a
year the formula so he's thinking about
this all the time for a year yeah to try
and articulate it the right way which by
the way according to him he did he did
articulate it the right way he says I've
been working on ask you this question
for over a year and this is the best way
I think I can articulate it this is it
the best way yeah okay so there's this I
thought you're gonna comment at least on
the fact that I told him to start
training jiu-jitsu yeah what I have
nothing that yes sir man jiu-jitsu is no
it's a real thing real time pure self
confidence yeah hang around with some
other people get choked out you get an
arm locked you're lifting weights yeah
maybe you're getting in shape maybe one
of those results one of the many results
of that might be but you won't be
compelled to try to correct everybody
everywhere you go like okay so sometimes
like I want to say all the time but if
people aren't asking for like advice not
all the time sometimes it works but if
they're not asking for advice you can't
just just well unsolicited be correcting
people how often are you walking around
just standing by and hoping that
everyone gives you advice on stuff
there's not a lot of people like that
yeah I mean it's really rare but there
is a time okay back to my brother Jade
you stuck in sand with his trunk why so
he wasn't stuck stuck but he was he was
getting stuck and we could all see him
he was kind in the distance there and he
started starting to get stuck and
there's all kinds of techniques to get
unstuck incense all kinds of technics
traction but there's a protocol it's
pretty standard or whatever so he's
beginning to get stuck in our other
friend Richard who is he the most
tactful guy in the world
sounds like a no every single moment of
his life maybe maybe not and at this
particular moment it wasn't so I see
Richard walking over there about to go
give Jade cement
how do not get stuck right is he
qualified to give advice and his shade
should Jade be taking advice at this
point okay
well that's another question to me if
you're about to get stuck if it really
seems like you're about to get stuck and
someone's gonna offer you advice to not
get stuck yeah I think logically right
you should take the advice but little
we're dealing with the real world here
so Jade's about to get stuck Jade has a
protocol in his mind right he's not like
unaware of this protocol but he has it
in his mind but according to what what
seemed like what it looked like was in
Richards mind he didn't so Richards
aggressively running over there
aggressively going over there to give
him some unsolicited advice which he
obviously needs right and we can hear
any of the advice we can hear we only
see the body movements writing so you
see you know aggressively Richards
telling them whatever he's telling them
with his hand movements and all this
stuff you know Jade's like no reaction
you know the kind when you're real
annoyed but you have no reaction you're
just like kind of looking down or
whatever and he's like doing his own
protocol I mean our Richards like
coaching them aggressively not landing
at all falling on deaf ears as it were
and every time it's like every maybe
five ten seconds
Richard would like turn around and throw
his hands up as if to say this guy's not
listening to me and he did that maybe
three four times right so you could tell
it was not going to it over there so I'm
like all right so we're all watching it
me my other brother and we're kind of
laughing a little bit because we see the
scenario we see Jade getting stuck ER
and Stucker and Richard you know we just
see the whole thing playing out so later
on we kind of talk to Jade kind of
teasing them right like broad whining
you just just like listen or whatever
and he went into the that side of the
whole deal where it's like men you can't
like it's hard to listen when someone
just like jumps in your hole stressful
situation offering you all this like
whack advice in this whack kind of way
yeah there there's a ways to deliver
advice in critical situations like that
and even then most likely an indirect
approaches advised and that's if they
okay and in this situation to hit or it
doesn't matter what it looked like to us
it looked what it looked like to richard
is like oh this car obviously needs my
advice
right now obviously in Jade's mine he's
like I I've done this before so so so I
had a conversation with somebody on EF
online the other day I was saying look
in this situation you you should
approach with an indirect approach yeah
and then as I'm talking to her I can see
that she's not she's kind of annoyed and
she actually was like like a logic and
facts based thing look like why can't I
just say the logic and facts with what's
going on and then have everyone just get
on board with the program well it kind
of was the thought process right and I I
said you know I can see that this
bothers you because what you're saying
from your perspective is look I know the
facts it doesn't make any sense that I
waste all this time trying to you know
take this indirect approach to try and
get someone to understand the facts so
we can change the direction that we're
going or adjust the plan accordingly
that's just dumb I said I can see that
on your face here's the thing if you
take a direct which which is why we're
having this conversation by the way you
take a direct approach and it doesn't
work so you don't adjust the plan I'm
suggesting you take an indirect approach
which will actually work and yes it will
take a little more time upfront but the
result will be positive so if Richard
would have taken an indirect approach
and walked over and and it would why
should I have to tell Jade that and uh
why should I have to take I could just
tell him hey you need to put it reverse
rocket or whatever advice he had to give
him if you'd have gone over and said you
know hey do you do you want me to tell
you where your tires are at or something
like that just a nice just a little
indirect jump you don't jump on his team
yeah just jump on his team and then all
of a sudden Jade's mind is openoffice in
there literally on the same team just by
saying hey you only put some weight on
the front for you or you know whatever
hey um you know do you want me to throw
some extra whatever you whatever you do
to get on the team and then
you're you're gonna win in the end and
the indirect approach which seems like a
big pain in the ass out of the gate oh
my god I can't believe I have to do this
and play this game
I have to play this game like yeah
listen to what I'm talking to you about
play the game because you will actually
get accomplished what you want to have
get accomplished as opposed to where you
know I'm just gonna open to take a
direct approach
to tell them what's up people aren't
ready to receive it and so it's useless
and so true like you and I'm thinking
back to the tire to getting stuck in the
sand scenario to where and here's the
thing to do it to make it matters worse
like it's cabrito
it's reasonable to assume that how
Richard came up to him wasn't like hey
like we we got a problem let's do this
it wasn't that it was like a dummy stuck
in the sand dummy like you know what
you're doing kind of kind of it I'm not
sure what he said but it seemed like
that was the approach right not only the
direct approach it was just now you get
immediate defensive this I'm not listen
to anything you say I would rather get
stuck out yep then listen to you that
was literally like what I felt like it
seems like Jade right now would way
rather get stuck and then listen to
Richard right now and quite frankly I
don't blame him the way Richard was like
throwing up his hands like oh my gosh
you're so dumb kind of the kind of a
thing like again I didn't hear what he
said but that's what that's what his
body language was saying I'll tell you
that so man I kind of I felt them I felt
them so yeah man let's hope that this
guy here can actually listen to what
we're saying I mean it in the most
positive possible way I think you can
get out of this situation but you got to
take ownership of what's going on
and you got to make some real changes
hit us back up hit me back up on that
that'd be cool I'd like to hear how it
all works out there's one layer of
positive feedback
Jordan Peterson I think it was on Joe
Rogan alone you know how they make this
like Jordan versus yeah yeah okay so it
what he said God was part of um he got
made into that right part of it ended so
he was like um it was like everybody's
rejecting you everybody's rejecting yeah
it's you Yeah right kind of thing and
it's funny because it's like did the
tone that he said it but that's kind of
irrefutable logic right there you know
where it's like man you're kind of like
the girl the it's a joke I think I'm
pretty sure it's a joke the girl who
goes through the doctor and says hey
like my my finger hurts or whatever you
know like when I touch here like my
finger hurts or whatever and then the
doctor goes okay
but the solution is don't touch there
you know kind of thing Fred that's like
it's real obvious to people you know
it's the tortured genius that life talks
about an extreme ownership oh hey look
I'm right and everyone else just doesn't
see the brilliance of my you know what
I'm doing look no one sees how brilliant
I am yeah no one sees how brilliant I am
the other two thumbs and yeah it's just
horrible for me and it's like no
actually maybe you're not right
something's not very nice your
approaches wrong route next question is
it necessary to explain the why of what
you're doing as a leader if you're not
ever asked why my varsity athletes never
questioned anything as I assume they're
either think that I'll it'll be
disrespectful or because they simply
think they need to follow my directions
yeah they should absolutely know why and
people on your team do not need to ask
you why for you to tell them you should
tell them why they're doing what they're
doing that way they can lead that way
they have a deeper understanding of what
they're doing that way they know how to
act and what to do when you're not there
which you won't always be there and when
you do that they actually learn they're
actually learning how to leave
themselves because they start to
understand the importance of knowing why
so you know this this this this happens
to me I mean there's a lot of people
that have worked for me over the years
that I didn't need to tell them why to
do anything well they were ready to rock
and roll right they did not care I mean
you think JP ever looked at me
said hey hey sir can you explain to me
why you want me to do that
no he's like JP machine-gun nest attack
he's attacking like by the by the time I
get my out of my mouth he's going so
there was no read there's no reason
there's never gonna ask me why mmm you
know at least not back then you know now
that we work together all the time if
I'm like hey I think we should do this
he'd say well why do you want me to do
that because he's you know he's running
ft X's and he knows what's going on more
than I do so if I tell him to do
something when I ask him to do something
he might say well why do you want me to
do that what's the effect you looking
for it so it's different now but my
point is much like a varsity athlete you
know that respects their coach and likes
the coach and wants to do a good job
well when JP was 21 years old he wasn't
asking me why to do anything and you
know for that matter that was that was
true for a lot of people that have
worked for me over the years like they
trust me and they don't they don't need
to know why they're doing what they're
doing they're gonna do it they're gonna
do it to the best of their ability that
doesn't mean that I don't tell them why
because I absolutely should cuz if you
don't know why you're doing what you're
doing you can't read decentralized
command doesn't work can't make
decisions in the field so even with
football athletes it's cool that they're
totally just on board but you should
still tell them why because it's a good
principle to follow in any leadership
situation yeah yeah especially as a
coach to men that'll like supercharged
like the learning process I think or the
training process like even like in
jujitsu there's good examples I get like
hip escape or shrimping right you know
when you first start or whatever if
you're just doing across the mat you're
getting taught how to do it and all the
stuff and you're kind of like I don't
really get why we're doing it good right
now you're gonna you find out yeah you
just do it cause everyone else to do it
what are you gonna do a new martial arts
class and you're gonna start asking then
so actually your actual an example is if
you know why you're learning the hip
escape then you do it with better intent
and no one could tell just by watching
you do it whether what your intent was
or not even though they might get a
little scent of your intent but it's one
of those situations if you know why
you're doing it you're gonna do it
better just like if you're coaching
football and you got guys running a
certain thing they're not gonna ask you
why but if you tell them why they know
why they're do
they're gonna do they're gonna do it
better yes so true the football thing
because in football you do kind of some
some oddball things if you just see it
on the surface
you know there's thing called grass
drills right where you just basically
you get your feet like you kind of run
in place real fast like kind of a little
bit wider stance and then you like
basically you sprawl you know yeah and
you know you hit the ground you get back
up real quick and then you and they do
there's all these drills you do right
they face the ball this way then you
turn and then you come back and you're
chopping your feet the whole time right
so on on the surface I remember when I
was like little doing that I remember
thinking oh yeah this is just like
conditioning really like moving your
whole body conditioning getting back up
would but after a while you're like nah
because if you get knocked down which
you will like pro football you get
knocked down like three times and within
like 15 seconds you know like the faster
you can get up and start running again
it's like bruh that's a good skill to
have you know kind of thing so if you're
drilling that every single day every
single day every single day not only do
you get better and quicker at that it
becomes way more instinctual so okay
then there's a lot more to it obviously
but men if someone was explaining that
to you every time you're doing it like
even just yelling it out just calling it
out as it's happening like good this is
gonna get you guys up quick when you get
knocked down on a play button you know
just yelling it out who cares whatever
you don't have to sit him down and say
this is what you're doing these guys you
don't have to say that necessarily I'm
saying in a football situation but if
you're going through that training with
that in your mind like oh I know why I'm
doing this but oh you're gonna you're
gonna charge that thing and you know
problem-solve better while you train
yeah man it's yeah it goes deep unknown
I said when I was coaching a lot of MMA
fighters I would always be telling them
why they're doing a drill and it made me
think of when you were saying you know
even if they're just yelling to you you
know yeah I'd be like this is the end of
the round this is where you're gonna you
know yes if you're down here this is
where you're gonna have to get back up
this is where the fight gets one like
yeah you know cuz you know some fighters
if they get taken down and they're a
striker and they're going against a good
grapple if they could take a now they're
gonna have to get back up to win the
fight you know and so when they know
that you can see it compute in their
brain whereas if I'm just saying it get
back up ya know so tell people why
we think one more question sir I've
listened to all of the podcasts before
asking this question can you please
explain how do you deal or I have dealt
with your insecurities thank you very
much for you I guess broadly
fundamentally what I'm gonna do with my
insecurities um is I'm gonna confront
them I'm gonna put them out there I'm
gonna own them I'm gonna hone them I'm
gonna hone my insecurities if I had to
think of examples of situations where
insecurities came into play for me one I
was going through buds basic SEAL
training and there was an event called
pool competency where you are wearing
your underwater breathing apparatus your
scuba gear and they do all these
horrible things to you and it's a very
hard evolution and I failed it and I was
confident going into because I kind of
done well most of the water things
underwater knot-tying life savings etc
etc etc I had done what I was
comfortable in the water mm-hmm and so I
was a I when I failed this thing which
was which was I was freaked out you know
and because people would fail pool comp
and get kicked out of buds you know it's
a nightmare for me
so I fail and by the way if you fail so
you take it on Friday and then if you
fail you take it again on Monday and if
you fail again you're rolled the back
and then once you rolled back now you
fail something else and you're gone so
it's a nightmare for me
I mean I'm um completely I've gone from
confidence to insecurity about this
thing so what did I do me and a couple
of the other guys we I don't know why
the instructors let us do this they
could probably get in trouble for it but
they they let us take the scuba gear and
use it in the dip tank which is just a
big bucketful I mean a big container
full of water probably four feet deep
and it's probably eight feet long
by four feet wide so it's just a small
where it's where you will you take fresh
water and you put things to clean it you
put it in fresh we call it a dip tank so
they they let us fill the dip tank up
with wasn't a totally unsupervised and
we went in there we pull comput each
other so we ripped each other's master
off beat each other to hell and just
trashed ourselves and by the time I went
on on Monday I was that insecurity that
I had was now gone because we had been
so freaking harsh to each other that by
the time I was rolling there I was like
yeah this isn't even insecured I'm like
burning it
go bring what you got I'm ready so
that's a that's one way to overcome that
I look at is something I was insecure
nervous about right how am I gonna
overcome and I'm gonna attack it
I'm gonna I'm gonna go straight into
that thing into that insecurity another
thing I was thinking about was kind of
funny was I was like at a bar when I was
young and single and whatever hanging
out you know having some beverages and
I'm chatting with some girl that I met
and you know as we're talking with yeah
just kind of just talking having a good
time whatever and she's like ah you know
what do you do you know well I'm a
dental hygienist she's a dental
hygienist and I was like oh that's cool
and then she says like something like
you know we could take care of that gap
in your teeth and like without missing a
beat I'm like are you serious I didn't
know that you could expand gaps how much
bigger could you make it and you know
like she was she was like totally I
don't know if the word stoked but she
realized that this whatever you know
this gap between my teeth which some
people might have as a big insecurity
like oh you know cover your mouth it's
fine like there it is I'm making fun of
it basically make it so that's I think
that is the bottom line when you have
some kind of in something that you're
insecure about it well if it's something
that you can take control over Colt then
attack it and get good at it you know if
you're if you're insecure about talking
in front of people cool attack that
problem and get better at it if you're
insecure about you know confrontations
with people start training in jiu-jitsu
if you're insecure or whatever whatever
you're insecure about do it more if
you're insecure if you think I every
time I write an email I feel like I'm
you know it's it looks like jong-kul
write more get better at writing it so
there's insecurities that you have like
that that you can attack if there's
something that you can't change or that
you can't control then just get it out
there and have fun with it as far as I'm
concerned you know dude make does that
make sense is that a bad answer no
that's a good answer
in fact it's those very clever response
to the dental hygienist the dental
hygienist wanting to fix the gap in my
teeth
so that I think that's good for
questions you know and hey it's a
interesting times right now what is it
it's it's April 2020 a lot of mayhem
going on in the world
everything from well we got viruses you
know and it's the tornadoes and just all
kinds of things and you know as I look
at what's going on it's just a gentle
reminder to everybody and maybe a not so
gentle reminder that the world is a hard
place the world is a hard place in the
world has it has no mercy the world does
not care nature does not care disease
and disaster and viruses and violence
and this is the thing that you need to
remember is that even time itself even
just time itself is picking you apart
picking you apart slowly every minute of
every day time is
taking you down and if you stare at that
stuff long enough if you stare at those
things long enough then just like the
Sun it it'll blind you and so I say
don't stare at it don't stare at those
things don't let them possess your brain
don't let them take over your mind
because just like the Sun can bind you
the Sun also the Sun also gives us light
and it gives us warmth and it gives us
life and those dreadful things in the
world they may win in the end and I can
actually guarantee the time we'll time
we'll win in the end but it's not gonna
win right now so in the meantime make
sure you live make sure you give it
everything you got make sure you leave
it all on the field and live your life
not blinded by the Sun but fueled by it
and I think that's all I've got for
tonight
tobacco Charles speaking of fuel I know
we need some clean fuel for our
undertakings whether the clean fuel no
excuses and wait there's something else
to it there is something else all right
what is it chuckle clean pool clean fuel
no excuses that's a good one
you're missing one apparently all right
well hey we're gonna revisit that last
one another time but in the meantime
what we can do is you're probably
forgetting the most important one maybe
it's hard work
all right and hard work that's why I
will reach other lass yes hard work
clean fuel no excuses there you go
origen USA mm-hmm by the way but before
we need the clean fuel we gonna do hard
work but it's better in my opinion to do
hard work doing something that you enjoy
mm-hmm and that's gonna benefit you by
the way explain why you're doing what
you're doing well then that gives you
physical training physical strength
physical stamina and confidence yes sir
we're hoping that the Holmes goes out
and starts training so just get that
confidence up capability across before
the rank
any more capable and increases your
confidence yes sir big time
so we're training jiu-jitsu we're
working out working out and trained you
just well well at this very moment you
just kept oof therefore to minimum we'll
say a minimum really which is the safe
and right thing to do by the way like
you'd think like that sounds debatable
mm-hm right now you know we did that
podcast with handy we did a grounded
podcast with Andy and we it when we
recorded it but like we were talking
about jujitsu and whatever and people
like training is morally irresponsible
and something's like we're history
well for what we didn't but I don't even
remember what phase of you know all that
was going on
but yeah so the bottom line is that you
are correct
right now jujitsu training is kind of a
debatable yeah big for everybody
yeah and it's and I don't want to get
too into like what you know where where
we stand on like the whole thing or
whatever but there's like a big picture
small picture scenario going on and it
in a short-term and long-term scenario
kind of playing out like it always does
um and like I think like if you're doing
okay so this term like falling on the
right side of the fence of history or
something like that right we're okay
we're trying this thing we're just we're
ready for it to be done this whole deal
quarantine all this stuff we're ready
for it to be done so there's certain
things you can do and not do to kind of
help facilitate the passing of this
thing and then those things that kind of
don't help the facility this help
facilitate the path some of these things
and there's things you can do that halt
the passing of this thing okay that Jam
us all up right okay so the question is
what are we doing
so try it so what exactly right but for
everybody but you know the things the
likes the short term long term short
term you're gonna have to you're gonna
have to take a hit short term mm-hmm and
I mean small pictures you'd used to and
a bunch of other stuff whatever just is
getting better even when I'm not
training because I'm studying yeah let's
see and there you go mental reps may be
getting some some stuff but you know I
know the thing is it's a two sided
situation that has to be like it's
they're battling with each other and
it's kind of its kind of wax a dichotomy
it's a dichotomy nonetheless
when we get back to jujitsu if we
weren't already in jujitsu and we're
gonna start jujitsu when we can we're
gonna get a geek we're gonna get a
ration card that's just the sort of the
uniform really best gay in the world
origin key yeah well it's just so
everyone knows hey look we made jujitsu
keys we make jeans we make boots right
at this moment in time
April 2020 we actually have shifted to
making face coverings is the term right
because the President and the CDC and
the government has
said to wear face coverings so we
started making face coverings we
actually shut down our other lines to
make face coverings for people so that's
what's going on right now at origin main
comm we will get back to manufacturing
jeans boots t-shirts of the whole nine
yards there's still some stuff in stock
as far as Gees and stuff go but right
now that's what we're focused on is
trying to get help America get through
this scenario that we're in right now
and so you can you can check out those
masks if you want them we won't be
making them for a long just because
other people are starting to catch up
and so we were able to pivot very
quickly because we have the entire
supply chain right there we own
everything we make everything there's no
like we have everything in-house so Pete
and the team in origin was able to
really quickly start making these face
coverings and so as other companies
start to make make them we'll go back to
making what we want to make you know no
one wants to be in the business of
making masks right but that's what the
country needs so that's what we're doing
right now if you want to get one of
those yeah you can get them in origin
main comm or trying to make them as fast
as we can and so that's one way to help
America get through this
they're not n95 masks right there
they're what they're what we can make
which is face coverings which is what is
in demand you know like I went to a
meeting the other day on a construction
site and you know what you have to wear
a face covering yeah so what am I
wearing I'm wearing an Origin face curve
that's what it's made for it's not made
for me to go and work in an ER no it's
it's made to show respect to someone
I'll tell you look I don't want to call
on you I don't want if I have it which
no one knows if you have it or not
because a lot of people are asymptomatic
so you wear this thing to protect the
people around you you know strangers
normal people and what you're doing
there is you're going back to what you
were saying earlier you are doing your
best to halt the the disease so we can
get back to normalcy so if you want one
of these masks go to origin main comm
and you can get one there also the we
have a bunch of supplements there
so if your and I know this is a you know
we've seen a huge spike in like milk
right because people don't want to go to
store there's starting to be a shortage
of food if you get Mol you know if you
get more which is good tasting protein
and we were selling a ton of milk right
now because people know that it's a good
thing to have you know in your house
because you can feed your kids you can
figure you can I don't know I don't I
don't know how to make the claim that
you know however you long you could
survive on more coldly but it's a great
it's a it's a great thing to have in
your house as as food suppliers are
getting shut down because of the virus
or whatever so we've been selling a ton
of milk we been selling a lot of we sold
out of of Cold War which is like an
immune system booster we just got it
back in stock so that's been selling
like crazy because it's got you know
it's got things that help boost your
immune system again is this a is this a
origin or is this a co vid fight
destroyer no it's just gonna help your
immune system so people don't want to
get sick right now
so that's been selling a lot but that's
what we're doing at origin right now
it's it's you know different it's
different times what else what am I
missing
yeah I mean the RET their supplements
you know the the joint warfare that's
one thing that's going on right now a
lot of people are working out you know
hardcore you're gonna need that joint
warfare krill oil so we got all that
stuff still but yeah if so if you want
to check that stuff out you can check
that out we're also with like the we're
making some fitness equipment we you
know like plyo boxes yeah we just
started making pile boxes why look our
goal is not to make file boxes here's
the deal America is sold out apply on
boxes right now and so people want them
because they're shifting to a home gym
scenario yeah so we just started
manufacturing those so if you want to
get a pile box you can go and we'll look
we're doing what we can to help get
through this situation we just made a
another thing which you saw the burden
it's like old I know ones it's what it's
like a kettlebell slash Bulgarian bag
slash medicine ball slash any other
slashes old boxing glove I don't know
old box yeah so we got thing called a
burden which I need to be able to use
for kettlebell exercises but it's made a
leather it's badass look so yeah
what do you explain the history or now
or the you know I mean the long history
is I have an idea I had an idea which I
talked to Pete a while ago we
brainstormed of making something called
the burden which was something you could
just carry we could just carry the
burden with you all the time right
so no matter what's happening you carry
the bird you can put it in your backpack
you can put in your briefcase you can
and you're constantly carrying around
you know 2030 pounds worth of extra
weight which just makes you stronger so
but you know it's you know do you go
through a development process and you
look at you know what what what
resources do we want to put on doing
this from the company and right now
again a bunch of people are saying
they're they have to work at home now
work out at home and they can't cuz they
don't have any equipment well how can we
make good you know what can we make that
would make it possible for people to
work out at home better this is one of
those things you know everybody wants I
mean you the amount of it the amount of
different workouts you can do with a
kettlebell is phenomenal so this and
kettlebells are you know sold out
everywhere yeah all gym equipment is
sold that everybody in everywhere sold
it's crazy because my what you know my
wife's talking their little groups and
all this stuff and the everyone's asking
her like hey do you guys have any extra
weights and I'm like like why is
everyone asked why is this Jennifer
fletchinder garden class asking about
kettlebells gyms because the gyms shut
down and they're like hey they know that
we have a you know bunch weights or
whatever but it was crazy how many
people were asking us like hey do you
have any extra my neighbor is like hey
do you have any extra weight so
everything extra weight unfortunately I
don't have any extra weights like a you
literally like every I have to day work
like the work uh programs one day one
day two and they just repeat so I use
all my way to all of them there's
literally two wait
weights that I don't use in yeah sure
enough they just came and grabbed him or
whatever so it's like men yes something
we need that the burdens on lining get
oh yeah so that's the thing is well
it'll ship with no weight in it like
you'll fill it with shop with steel
bearings or LED shot or whatever you
know sand or rocks depending on how
heavy you want it but yeah the bottom
line is we're very lucky we're very
lucky because none other sizes I will
don't want to just call it luck but to
have the capability to own the supply
chain and be able to make things that
that that all of a sudden are in demand
like there's not too many people that
can pivot and go from manufacturing
boots because it's all in America it's
all it's all under one roof hey we can
make these and we can make them starting
in a day or two days and that's exactly
what we're doing is trying to try to
give people what they need during this
crisis and it's been great so far so if
you guys want to check that stuff out if
you need a plyo box at your house and or
if you need a burden to carry you can
check that out masks whatever they're
there as well and then all the all the
different all the different supplements
are there so you appreciate the support
and if you want if you guys have ideas
or whatever you see a demand for
something let us know cuz that's what
we're doing
we're trying to help look-the obviously
we we want to get back just like anyone
else
everyone else we want to get back to
making jeans boots and geese that's what
we want to make and shorts and t-shirts
and everything else but when there's a
when there's a need we we have to try
and help you know get through this so
yeah also we have a store
Jaakko store.com its online store we're
you know an amazon there they're the
only shit the only ship certain items
quicker now yeah you buy stuff through
Amazon it can take like a month four
weeks you know yeah what's interesting
about that is for origin supplements on
Amazon those are in the
at aghori of getting shipped like
immediately yeah essential items yeah
it's you know they looked at the
products that we make and the health
items and that just put us in the
category so if you want to get Molk if
you want to get joint warfare if you
want to get Cold War you can get it from
Amazon right now and it's on that list
of stuff that's considered essential
which is which is awesome yeah yeah yes
and yeah that is you know what I did was
that when I know I was going through the
list with with Jeff and just pointed out
some of the things that we had that I
thought America needed sure mmm there
you go mmm me and bees else we go way
back yeah yeah good good relationship
building that's a really bad attempt
little Joe
I respect the less the newzeas jockle
store is okay is your get after it just
food equals freedom shirt or hoodie like
is that an essential item yeah maybe
we'll just say it's debatable I don't
know it depends on who you are I'm not
gonna make some crude and kind of
comparison but you know that look
there's no answer for that maybe there
is maybe there isn't I don't know about
the claim I know with my irrefutable
logic or nothing like this but we are
shipping normal assume saying you don't
have to wait the four weeks normal
shipping you know maybe some here and
there if there's like a big influx or
whatever because of like you know the
staffing and stuff but shipping against
normal so that's good news anyway taco
store calmness where you can get your
discipline equals freedom shirts hoodies
rash guards a fee hey get get a rash
guard man I think we have some still but
be cool on the jiu-jitsu just for now
mm-hm just be careful with it
careful with what we gain unless yeah I
see what you're saying yes you're
putting forth a positive message yes on
both but do you wear a rash guard when
you just lift I don't know but I
inference yeah oh yeah like some rings
and stuff rings for sure rings for sure
like of that little bit of comfort yeah
and also let the protection yeah of your
arms because when you're doing a lot of
let's say muscle ups are doing a lot of
dips or ring push-ups yeah you can get
the chafing on your outer arm
yeah I can dig it so yeah keep that in
mind for sure but but yeah well cool
stuff on there I think so yeah if you
want something get something we'll get
it to you also subscribe to the podcast
see if you haven't already on iTunes or
stitcher Google Play where we listen to
iTunes is it essential but I think so
nowadays because let's face it man we're
just doing less you know we're at the
house more all the stuff like good
consumable stuff good consumable stuff
podcast books audio or otherwise like
there's this gonna be more of that I
think that's that's good that helps us
through this scenario so subscribe to
the podcast is what echoes saying in a
really long roundabout way which is fine
by me I guess we got we're on we're on
quarantine degree no one cares about but
it's all good and we just started
another podcast called the thread it is
myself and Daryl Cooper of Margar made
Fame he famous yes okay so Daryl Cooper
and I he was on the last podcast and the
the podcast the thread is launched we
also have grounded podcast where we talk
about life and jiu-jitsu sure and
everything in between and then we got
the warrior kid podcast which you may
have missed a release of Johnny Kim on
the warrior kid podcast so go check that
out
and also when you're talking about
warrior kids don't forget to check out
Irish Oaks ranch calm where Aiden a
warrior kid is making soap making killer
soap and that's the name of the soap
making killer soap so that America and
stay clean yep
also YouTube we have a YouTube channel
wash your hands
what I wash your hand oh yeah the big
deal right now wash your hands yeah so
get yourself some you know some warrior
kids soap some some killer soap you know
kill the germs man yeah kill the virus
I heard that so kills yeah they're
saying so just like soap kills the virus
yeah washing it off maybe I don't know I
think it kills well cuz the virus can't
live it without a sustainable what
habitat right it's like one of those
situations okay look I'm no germ ologist
by a biological expert nothing like this
but from what I understand it the virus
can live only for a certain amount of
time on on surfaces because it can't eat
nothing mmm right can't live it's like a
virus bro oh it's eating stuff if it's
living it's eating trust me then we're
already looking at impossible unless we
have a YouTube channel video version is
podcasts and excerpts yes
enhanced and otherwise yes little
excerpts help you through the day
through the times through situations
that may arise scenario scenario health
scenarios all day for sure
well yeah YouTube channel chuckle
podcast YouTube channel good yeah and
this the excerpts have been getting
let's just say give you a little credit
here they've been getting a little bit
better lately cool not the enhanced ones
cuz I haven't seen one of those in a
while cuz I know you've been busy doing
other things it's like a logical warfare
you can get that the little
psychological hitter to help you get
through moments of weakness that's the
artist formerly known as jock a willing
on iTunes on mp3 whatever flipside
canvas messages for you in graphic form
made by Dakota Meyer you can check that
out flipside canvas calm got a bunch of
books leadership strategy and tactics
way the warrior kids one two and three
Mikey and the dragons discipline equals
freedom Field Manual extreme ownership
dichotomy leadership all kinds of good
books for you to check out
we got a national on front leadership
consultancy where we solve problems
through leadership go to echelon front
comm for details on that
we've got EF online which has been
revamped reformulated according to echo
Charles live that's what it is live
interactive it is myself
it is lave Bab and is the entire a
chillon front team on there virtually
we're doing online live three times a
week right now live Q&A s so if you want
to ask me a question go to EF online.com
we got the leadership primer we got the
forum we got the Q&A we got immediate
action jokes we got all kinds of stuff
to help you lead and this is the type of
time right now where there's mayhem
going on leadership is what is needed
so check out EF online.com it's it's
it's awesome I think it's gonna be the
platform that becomes the premier way
for people to get help
in leadership in the world and I know
that's a bold statement I'm making it
also we got the musters Orlando
cancelled so that means next up Phoenix
Arizona September 16th and 17th Dallas
Texas December 3rd and 4th go to extreme
ownership comm for details
look we've sold out everything we've
ever done we actually canceled the show
and a lot of the people that cancelled
Orlando moved over to Dallas and/or
Phoenix so we're gonna fill out we're
gonna we're gonna sell out faster than
normal so if you want to come extreme
ownership calm and then EF overwatch
which has executive leadership it's our
placement firm where we take leaders
that understand the principles we talk
about and we place them into companies
we also have that's for executive
leadership for frontline leadership we
got EF Legion calm look we are getting I
know it's financial troubles right now
with a lot of companies there's also a
lot of companies that have a massive
demand and we are getting hit up to have
two four four employees people that want
to hire so if you're a veteran go to EF
Legion comm and sign up so we can get
you connected with people that are
looking to hire and if you haven't had
enough of my head splitting gear
overly aggressive voice or you haven't
had enough of echoes random
semi-coherent postulations then you can
tune into us and connect with us on the
interwebs on Twitter on Instagram and on
G face II bow echo Charles is at echo
Charles and I am at Jocko willing kin to
all of you that are overseas right now
in uniform keeping evil at bay during
these troubled times thanks for what
you're doing in the police law
enforcement firefighters paramedics EMTs
dispatchers correctional officers Border
Patrol Secret Service thank you for
keeping us safe on the home front and
special thanks to all the doctors nurses
and all medical personnel that are on
the front lines every day right now
you're out there risking your health to
keep the illness the virus at bay so
thank you for your courage and sacrifice
and everyone else out there life is not
perfect and it isn't going to be easy
but it is all you've got so make it a
good run and make sure you enjoy the jam
and you do that by getting out there
every day and getting after it and until
next time does echo and Jocko out